- Hello, hello, hello, hello?
Testing. Testing.
Testing.
- How do we podcast?
(laughing)
- How do I talk
to real human beings?
(digital chirping)
(laughing)
Do we just start?
- What was that?
- Do we just start?
- What do we do?
What do we do?
(gentle music)
Hello, gamers,
and welcome to the next
episode of, "Trash Taste".
Fucking I stuttered already.
- What is this,
midnight radio?
(laughing)
Hello there.
- I don't want,
I don't even want to pretend
I have energy right now.
(laughing)
I'm coming in
with a chill class today.
- You don't have any energy?
- I don't know. It's-
- You're the host, Garnt.
You should come up with host energy.
- Hello, everyone,
and welcome to this
episode of, "Trash Taste".
I am your host for today, Garnt.
There, there, there.
Was that enough energy, Connor?
Was that enough energy?
- Who are we?
Who are we?
I don't know who we are.
- Who are we?
- I am Garnt,
and once again, I'm joined
by my host, Connor and Joey.
- Oh, wow.
- How have you boys been?
- We've been all right.
How have you been
(Garnt laughing)
is more the question.
- How've you been, Garnt?
- I've not been all right.
Well, I mean,
(co-hosts laughing)
I've certainly been in isolation.
If you didn't know, this
is actually the first time
we've filmed in three weeks now
because we took two weeks off.
- Yeah, three weeks.
- I don't know about you boys,
but not filming for three weeks
felt like three years for me.
- Yeah.
- Especially for me
because I go on Twitter,
I go on social media, I
see you guys streaming,
doing all of your shit,
and here I am just being like,
"Just some bed ill. Just,
can't really talk, can't-"
- I mean, I don't think
anyone can fault you for that.
I mean, you got fucking COVID,
of course you're going to be sick.
- So if you didn't know, I, unfortunately,
tested positive about two weeks ago now.
It's been, actually, 15 days
since I tested positive.
Now I have officially tested negative,
so I am safe
to film again with the boys.
- He's back. He's back.
- Welcome back. Welcome back.
- Just in case. Just in case,
I'm in my own
(laughing)
isolation corner right here.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We didn't plan this.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
I've been in isolation for 14 days and-
- How does it feel?
How does it feel to get COVID?
- It sucks.
Luckily-
- It feels American.
(laughing)
Just joking.
Fuck.
- Wow.
- I'm sorry.
We're British, too.
- It's been zero days.
(everyone laughing)
- I had to. I had to.
It's been three weeks.
- Three weeks and Connor's already,
How many minutes has that been?
- It was-
- I was just. I was just.
Connor was having withdrawal symptoms
for three weeks.
- You know, the vein busting.
- Been like, "I want a show so hard."
- My veins were bursting.
I hadn't insulted America in three weeks.
- I remember when I got it.
I was, honestly, a little bit salty.
I was a little bit salty.
Not because, Obviously,
getting COVID sucks,
but I was a little bit salty
because before I got COVID, I
hardly ever went out at all.
I didn't go out because
I spent all this time
marathoning all the great anime of 2021
to make my, "Best of Anime, 2021" video.
So I was just inside. Just
watching all the best shit.
Watching all this anime. Didn't go out.
I went out, Aside from,
"Trash Taste" recordings,
I went out once,
and the only time I went
out was with these boys.
That was, literally,
the only time I went out
in the past two weeks
prior to me catching COVID.
- I think I figured it out.
- [Garnt] You think you figured it out?
- I know why you got it.
I think the air, when you're six foot,
is high enough.
(Garnt laughing)
- COVID was traveling
in the six-foot sphere.
We're under the, sorry, Joe,
Under the six foot.
(Garnt laughing)
We couldn't breath it in.
- Wow.
(Garnt laughing)
- Hot air rises, right?
COVID rises.
- COVID rises.
- COVID is rising.
- I was about to say
anime gives you COVID.
(laughing)
I guess that's another hypothesis as well.
- That's the actual scientific,
We're not scientists. Do not take of that.
- COVID is the height equalizer.
(Joey laughing)
- We needed this. We needed this.
We need a win.
- They need to nerf six foot
or something now, right?
- Yeah. Yeah.
Obviously, when I tested positive,
I remember messaging these boys.
I mean, like, "Boy's, I got to be honest.
You should probably be careful
because, I'm not going to lie,
the only time I've been
out in the past two weeks
aside from, "Trash Taste",
which I'm also with the boys,
was with you guys when we off
to that one business meeting.
- Let me just say I'm glad I got that text
while I was on the toilet
because I did shit myself.
(Garnt laughing)
When I read that, I
was like, "Oh, my God."
- Would you have shit yourself
if you weren't on the toilet?
- Probably. Yeah.
- Oh, okay. Okay.
- I was like, "Thank God my pants are down
and I'm literally taking a shit."
- So I was like, "Brace
yourself, boys. It might come.
It might come."
- The storm's coming.
- Yeah. The storm's coming.
And then it didn't come.
And, apparently, I was
the only one who got COVID
in our entire office.
I mean, I say this because, I say this,
I'm happy that no one else got COVID
- Yeah.
- aside from me.
I'm happy. I'm happy.
- Why didn't anyone else get it?
I don't want to be the only one.
But as the guy who does not,
The only time we go out to make content
is for, "Trash Taste".
You boys, filming outside, going outside,
filming constantly, I'm just
like, " Why, why, why me?
Why is it me?
Why is it the nerd that stays
inside and watches anime
that gets COVID?
- Anime gives you COVID,
man. I'm telling you.
Why do you think I stopped watching it?
Because Sydney got it
as well, unfortunately.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sydney got it around two days
after me, which makes sense.
That was two days after
symptoms had set in.
Obviously, I'm glad that I was vaccinated
and I think it was Omicron as well
because my symptoms weren't too bad.
I remember I felt something coming.
(chuckles)
You know when you wake up
and you have a bit of a sore throat,
and you start shitting yourself?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Because you're just like,
"Oh, is this illness?"
- "Is this it?"
- "Am I getting ill?
Am I getting ill? Am I getting paranoid?"
I remember on the Thursday night,
Because I've been paranoid before about,
"Am I ill?" Or "Am I not ill?",
because I have a slight sore throat
or a slight cough or something,
but I remember Thursday night here,
and your body knows when
it's about to get ill.
I could feel that my body,
That a storm was coming in my body.
And I was praying to God
that it was just the flu
or some kind of normal, other illness.
But I knew that something
was coming and I was like,
I told Sydney, "Sydney, I
think I'm about to get ill.
I'm calling it now."
I'm calling it now.
- [Joey] See if you get ill.
- I'm going to get ill.
- "You can't be mad if I
get ill. I already said it."
(laughing)
- Like, "Honey, don't be mad.
Promise you won't be mad.
Promise you won't be mad. I
think I'm about to get it'll."
I didn't have a fever but
my body started to feel
a little bit groggy,
a little bit fatigued.
And I'm just like,
"I've felt this before."
I've felt this before.
I've gotten the flu or
that kind of illness
where it conks me out for a few days.
So I'm like, "Honey, don't be alarmed,
but I think I might be ill."
And then I went to sleep, woke up
and had a pretty high fever.
For me, at least.
I remember when we did
our second vaccination,
I had a fever of 38 degrees Celsius.
I don't know what that is in Fahrenheit.
On that Thursday,
- 12.
- It's not.
- On that Thursday,
- It's 12.
- On that Thursday, I started
off with a 38 degree fever.
So I was like, "Okay, I
definitely got a fever.",
went to get tested,
and then, by the time
nighttime came around,
that fever had gone up 40 degrees.
- Fuck it. Which is dangerous.
- Uh oh. Uh oh.
- Which is dangerous.
I was Googling.
I was Googling, "When should
I go to the hospital?"
- Spoiler, he lived.
(laughing)
- What is the, What is the
boiling point for human?
(laughing)
- Yeah.
Because normally when I
get the flu or something,
I go up to 39,
and I'm just like, Even then,
that's pretty high-
- That's a really bad cold
as well.
- That's a really bad cold.
So I was like, It was like,
I remember measuring myself,
getting to 40,
and then I remember Googling,
"How high does your fever need to be
to consider going to the hospital?"
And I remember Googling it,
and said, "After around 41 degree,
you should consider
going to the hospital."
And me, already drenched in sweat,
I start sweating even more,
because I'm just like-
- What do they, What can they
do there, if you have a fever?
It's like, "Oh, here's a bed. Lie down."
(Garnt laughing)
What can they actually do?
- Is it like placebo,
where because you're in a hospital,
you're going to get better sooner?
- Maybe, yeah.
Maybe they're like, "Oh, here's
an IV with nothing in it."
- Or maybe they give
you more stronger meds.
- Yeah. Maybe they give
But at least-
- Here's POCARI Sweat.
Shut the fuck up.
(laughing)
- This is hospital POCARI Sweat.
- But also, with some of these things,
Okay, go ahead. Go ahead.
I'll go on a rant after this.
I mean, all I was going to say is,
I mean, I feel like it
is a bit of a placebo,
but also, in case your
symptoms do get majorly worse,
there is someone there to
put you under intensive care.
Just in case.
- I'm absolutely terrified of hospitals.
It's the only thing I'm scared of.
- [Garnt] Oh, same here.
- I don't really-
- Well, I don't know anyone
who goes to the hospital and goes, "Yay."
- But some people don't mind.
They're like, "Oh, whatever."
But I'm like, I would
literally do anything
not to go to the hospital,
which probably means that
at some point,
I'm probably going to
come down with something,
and I should probably go
and get it checked out,
- And just die in bed.
- But I'm not going to.
But I'm not because I'm so
stupid that I'd be like,
"No. I'd rather not"
Because when I get ill, I
just never, ever assume,
"I should go to the hospital."
I just think, "Oh, I
should just ride it out."
But then you hear stories
about how people die from that,
and I'm like, "Aah."
- Yeah.
Because I feel like a
lot of this is part of,
I mean, I think a lot of this is part of
growing up in England as
well because, I think,
there's definitely a
difference in mentality
when it comes to illness,
especially when I started dating Sydney
and seeing how she handled getting ill
versus how I handled getting ill.
Because I'm just like, If I
have a fever, I'm just like,
"Jut take some paracetamol,
ride it out, whatever."
Just start sweating in bed.
- Sweat it out.
- Yeah. Sweat it out, sweat it out.
Because, in England, if
you go to see the doctor,
by the time you book an appointment
and you get the chance to go see the GP,
the fever's already gone.
The fever's already gone.
- You're either better or dead.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it's either you're bad
enough to go to the hospital
or you just don't go to the doctor at all.
But with Sydney, luckily,
Sydney had health insurance
when she was in, When she
was growing up in America-
- Stop bragging.
(laughing)
- Sure. Sydney's privileged, right?
Yeah?
- Yeah, right.
She had health insurance.
- Wow.
- Okay. Wow, health insurance.
So she would be like, If
she just got slightly ill,
"Just go see the doctor.
Just to make sure.
Just in case."
- [Joey] Use that health
insurance to your advantage.
- Use that health insurance.
Because you can just go see a,
So why would you not go see a doctor?
Me, dying in bed, being
like, "No, I don't see,
Sydney, I don't need to see a doctor.
I don't need to see a doctor.
Why would I need to see doctor?
It's only a 40 degree fever.
Google says I need to be 41
to go see a doctor, Sydney.
Come on. Come on.
I aint a pussy boy. I aint a pussy boy."
(laughing)
- It's true though.
In Japan, people are like
that, that's why, I think.
From what I heard,
(indistinct) people are like,
"I've got a headache.
I'm going to the clinic."
What? What?
No, no, no. You'll be fine.
I don't know. Just sleep it off.
I don't know. Maybe I'm being too harsh,
but then, do you ever find
that sometimes you're like,
I don't know if this is me thing,
but sometimes I'm getting sick,
I'm like, "No. Stop, body.
Stop. Stop, right now."
(laughing)
Don't do this.
- What? Did you develop Nen?
(laughing)
- I think I might have,
I don't know if this
is just me being stupid
but I just completely ignore it.
When I'm about to get sick,
I'm like, "We are not sick.
We will continue with our day
like everything is normal.
- That just sounds like copium to the max.
- Sometimes I feel like it works, though.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's
just pure luck or it's,
It's probably my own stupidity.
Sometimes I get ill, I
feel the illness coming,
and then, in my mind, I feel
like this is a deciding point.
In my he'd I'm like,
"Am I going to resign
myself to being ill?,
or am I going to be
like, "No, I'm not ill.
I'm going to continue on.
I'm going to eat healthy,
I'm going to do it."
I don't know.
This sound like some Joe Rogan-esque shit
I'm saying right now.
(laughing)
I don't know.
For small illnesses.
Obviously, if you've got some
kind of horrible illness,
it's like, "Yeah, no-
- The flu is controlled by the government.
- No amount of mind power is,
"Well, you know, it's
like a placebo effect."
This shit is completely nonsense.
We are not medical professionals.
- We're going to say this right now,
we are not medical professionals.
- This is a joke.
- It's not a joke. See?
I'm sorry.
(laughing)
I inject horse urine into my veins, Joey.
I don't know.
When it's a tiny illness,
when it's a sore throat,
something like that,
sometimes I feel like,
how much of your mental,
Mental willpower can affect it
because you hear about the placebo effect
affecting how you can perform
in certain situations.
I'm wondering, how much can that affect
your likeliness to get sick?
- I mean, I do feel like you're, Okay.
This is going to be complete
speculation bullshit.
- This is all anecdotal.
Any medical professional would
be laughing at us right now.
- This is completely anecdotal
but I do feel like your mentality
and your willingness to, I
don't know, accept something,
I feel like it does play some
kind of conscious affect.
Because you hear,
You hear about stories
about people who have a deadly illness
and because they have
the will to fight it,
some people are able to
fight through the illness,
and some people are more
inclined to give in.
So I do feel, based on zero,
zero fucking scientific proof,
and just based on total
anecdotal evidence,
that there is some kind of effect
that your mentality has
towards illnesses, sometimes.
Not every time.
(stutters)
People, I'm not saying
everyone who died from cancer
being like, You obviously
didn't try the fucking,
You obviously didn't try hard enough
- You didn't want it enough.
- You didn't fight it hard enough.
- You just have to get good.
- Cancer is just the, "Dark
Souls" of illnesses, guys.
Come on. You just got to get good, man.
(Joey speaks indistinctly)
You just got to get good.
I'm not trying to say that.
- That's why I'm saying
it's with little things.
With colds and stuff.
I feel like when I'm way more
up for being like, "Fuck you.
I'm going to just continue
with my day, mentally."
I don't know why.
- It's not like you do anything
to actually prevent it.
It's not like you take a fucking,
You eat honey or whatever.
- I go out of my way to not take anything.
I never take pain killers.
I hate taking them.
- To me, taking pain killers
is the point where I admit
defeat and I am actually ill.
Do you know what I mean?
Even this time, when I could
feel my body getting ill,
I was like, "No. It's
not it. I'm not ill."
I'm not going to go out,
obviously because it's a pandemic,
but I'm going to keep working.
I'm going to go by my daily schedule,
and I woke up and I'm like,
"38. That's a manageable fever.
I'll get tested. Come back. "
- I don't know.
38's pretty fucking high.
To me it was manageable until,
I remember sitting at my PC
on the first day that the
symptoms started rolling in.
Obviously, at this time,
I didn't get any of the test results,
so I had no idea, It could've
been a cold for all I knew.
I remember sitting down at
the computer, trying to work,
and it was just, as the day
went on, I was like, "No, body.
Don't do this. You're not ill.
You're not ill. Come on, body.
You can power through this."
And I remember, it was
around five o'clock,
where I was staring at the script,
and I was trying to get shit
done, no words would come out
because I was just too tired.
I was like, "Okay. I'm
absolutely fucking ill.
Let me take some fucking medicine.
Let me take my temperature
again. Let me do the fucking-
- I can just imagine you sitting
at your computer and just
(imitates Garnt)
(Garnt laughing)
It's like, "Oh, God."
- Sometimes you're like,
"Shit. My willpower wasn't
enough to beat this minor cold.
- Yeah.
- Shit.
- Who would've thought.
- It's just a perception,
man. It's a perception.
- It seemed that, I don't know,
painkillers and stuff like
that, I have friends who,
They'll take a painkiller
the moment they even
get a slight headache.
But I'm always really
worried because then they,
the same people, this
is completely anecdotal,
They're just like,
"Oh, yeah. It doesn't work as well anymore
because I take it too often."
And I'm like, "Well, that's scary.
I'm not going to take it
unless I'm really in pain."
And then I'll be like, "All right. Fine.
I'll take a paracetamol or something"
- Because what happens if they get, say,
a really massive headache or
worse still, where it's like,
"Oh, God."
If you don't have pain
medicine, you're just fucked.
You might faint. You might pass out.
Whatever, man.
- I always worry about stuff like that.
- I think the only scary thing, for me,
was because I'd never gotten COVID before.
Normally when I get an illness,
I've been ill enough times
to know how my body deals with it.
Like, "Okay. I'm going to
be out for X amount of days.
I need to do this."
I've got this down to a science.
I wake up with,
What's the throat-itis?
Tonsillitis or something,
which has happened a few times.
I'm just like, "Okay.
I'm going to be conked out for two days.
I'm not going to be able to
speak for three, four days,
and then afterwards,
I'll be completely fine.
But when I tested positive, I'm just like,
"Fuck. I've never done this before,
so this is all new territory for me, man.
How's my body going to react to it?
I've got asthma, is that
going to play an effect?"
I'm just like, It wasn't like,
I didn't have a bad time,
it was more of just the unknown
that scared me the most.
- Yeah. That's way scarier.
- Because it was something,
It was something completely new
that I had never experienced before,
so I had no prior knowledge
about how I should best deal with it,
or how my body was going to deal with it.
Luckily, It was fine.
Second thing that I shit
myself over was everyone saying
that you might lose your
sense of taste, I'm just like,
"You know what? I think
I'd rather go to hospital
than lose my sense of taste, honestly.
- What do you mean?
With the bread take you surely did.
I think a lot of people
would argue you already did.
- You sure you haven't gotten COVID?
- I think you should've gotten COVID
for the best "Trash
Taste" recording in years.
Half of these food takes-
- I don't think you have
any taste buds to kill.
The first thing that I
did when I tested positive
was, obviously I needed to inform Meilyne,
to inform GeeXPlus and
everyone in the office
that I tested positive,
and the first thing she
messages me about is,
"Oh, I've heard that COVID
might change your taste buds,
so maybe you'll be able
to taste bread now.
I'm just like, "Fuck you, Meilyne."
- Roasted
- This is not what I wanted to hear
when I tested positive, okay?
- Were you hungry at all?
Did you have an appetite?
- It wasn't exactly the same,
Okay. Here's the thing I
hate about being fucking ill,
is that it's, I didn't
lose my sense of taste,
it was just the same affect to your taste
that you have with any illness,
which just, for some reason,
everything just tastes shit.
Everything just tastes bland.
- Man, I get super hungry when I get sick.
- Yeah. I remember-
- That's so weird.
- Remember when you got
ill the few weeks before,
when you got tonsillitis,
you just ate a fuck ton.
And, to me, I can't eat at all
- Nah. Me neither.
- when I'm ill.
I just don't eat.
- It should mean my stomach is okay.
I have any other illness,
I'll just eat a lot.
I don't know why.
- For me, when I'm sick,
just the smell of food
is like, "Urg." For me.
- Do you remember that one
time I got food poisoning?
I got food poisoning this one time,
and then the next day,
while I was still dying,
I got so hungry.
Felt like McDonald's.
So I ordered a fuck ton of
McDonald's and I ate all of it.
Weirdly, I felt a lot better.
I don't know why.
I feel like I'm the only person on earth
who binged McDonald's
and then felt better.
- Because usually that's the thing
that gives you food poisoning.
- Yeah. That's exactly right.
You'd think eating McDonald's
after having food poisoning
is a bold choice.
It was really weird.
- You're really doubling down.
- Okay. Actually, the one
time I do regret doing this.
This one time I was really sick,
again, I think, with food
poisoning, the next day,
I know everyone is going to laugh,
I decided to get Indian curry.
That was actually a mistake.
- What? Why?
- Why would you do that?
- I was really craving butter
curry. I don't know why.
- I crave a lot of good
food when I'm ill as well,
but I've had it enough times
that you regret it immediately
once you take the first bite.
That was the only time I regretted it.
Other times I've gotten
it and I feel better.
I don't know if it's, in
my mind, I'm like, "Yeah."
Maybe my body's like, "Oh, shit.
We've got another problem to deal with.
Let's deal with that."
And then everything just gets better.
I don't know. I don't know.
It's a load of shit, really.
- Your brain works one step at time.
- I mean, it should be.
I don't know. It's all weird.
I feel like no one really
understands their body.
We're all just guessing.
We're all just doing,
We're like plague doctors
tying to figure out our thing,
with our own weird rituals.
I think we all just have a thing
that we feel comfortable with,
and somehow it works.
- Well, we've sorted it.
We've been ill enough times to know
how our body reacts to certain things,
and to deal with certain things.
Everyone bodies is different.
- Yeah.
I'll sit there and laugh
at all these plage doctors
from the 18th century,
and then I'll just be like,
"I'm going to will power my disease away."
It's only, really, Have we changed at all?
I don't think so.
I think we've just gotten
smarter while keeping the stupid.
- You know what will fix my sore stomach?
McDonald's.
- Dude, exactly. That's what I'm saying.
- Before COVID, how often did
you guys get sick per year?
- Once a year.
- Once a year?
- Are we counting food
poisoning because I feel like,
food poisoning, to me-
- You seems to get food poisoning a lot.
- Food poisoning, to me, I
don't count as getting sick.
- No. That's definitely sick.
- That is illness. That is illness.
- Hear me out. Hear me out.
Hear me out.
Because it's like if I poisoned
Garnt, you wouldn't be like,
"Oh, Garnt got sick."
You'd be like, Garnt was poisoned.
It's a different kind of vibe.
It's just sickness. It's not
like something you treat.
It's like, "You got food poisoning?
"Yeah. "You're fucked"
You're fucked. Just deal with it.
I don't know.
- What?
- What? Wait, do you know
what food poisoning is?
- Yes.
- It's not like someone slipped cyanide
into your McDonald's.
- No, I know. I know.
But it's like, It's not
caused by a natural cause
of sickness or a bacterial or virus.
It's like something went
wrong and fucked up.
- No. No.
- No. It is.
- It is. It is
- It is.
- No, I know. I know.
But it's not like you got
it by accident or something.
You know what I mean? Like
you stumbled across it.
Something had to go
wrong of it to be there.
- No, I think it's by accident.
- [Crew Member] Yeah.
- No. No
No.
- [Crew Member] You wouldn't know
if something's wrong with
the food unless you try it.
- No, I know.
That's why I'm saying
I don't count that as
the natural quote of getting sick.
Because, let's say you undercook chicken
and there's salmonella
in it, that's fucked.
You're done.
- Yeah.
But that's not the fault of the person
who undercooked the chicken,
that's the fault of the salmonella-
- Well, that is why you cook the chicken.
- Which is the disease
that comes naturally.
- Yeah.
But that's not something
you come across naturally.
That's not something you
would normally come across.
- What do you mean by "come across"?
Do you mean just on the street.
Be like, "Oh, there's salmonella."
- It takes something carried.
Garnt is carrying a
normal, I don't know, cold
or whatever.
It's a different category in my mind.
I don't know.
- Well, not every raw piece
of chicken has salmonella,
but there is a chance
that if you have a raw piece
of chicken and it's not cooked,
then the salmonella,
or the bacteria
- That's why we have steps to-
- will not be killed.
In the same way that if you go outside
and someone has COVID
or the flu or something,
and you stand next to them and they cough,
and then you inhale their particles,
- [Joey] You have a chance of getting it.
- then you have the chance of getting it.
- It's all right.
In my mind, I just put
it differently, I guess.
(Garnt laughing)
Because food poisoning is
normally just due to the lack,
Of somebody fucking up.
- You mean lack of-
- Like undercooking and stuff?
- Yeah. Yeah.
Undercooking and stuff like that.
Or bad meat. Bad storage.
- Not all the time, though.
It's just sometimes
- Not all the time.
- it might just be like a rogue-
- Well, like E.coli and shit.
Yeah. That's a big fuck up.
- Sometimes it's jus a matter of like,
"Oh, there was a piece of food there,
and just, unfortunately,
just a rogue disease
or virus just happened to
fucking stumble upon it.
- Well, I mean,
- And then you inhale it.
- it's different though.
Because then we-
- Are you saying that food
poisoning is more preventable?
- Yeah. Way more preventable.
But that's why you can be, Your
restaurant can be shut down
if you keep giving people food poisoning.
The majority of the time,
something like food poisoning
is due to somebody fucking
up in the chain of,
Because we have these steps.
- So, basically, the most times we get ill
is when someone has fucked up
and given you food poisoning.
Or you fucked up and given
yourself food poisoning.
- Mainly me. I look at it and
I'm like, "Aah. Fuck it.",
and then I eat it.
(Garnt laughing)
And then I shouldn't have.
- So that's why you don't
count it as getting it ill
because it's on you.
It's on you.
- If I just walked pass someone
in the street who was ill,
I don't count that as the same thing.
I don't know.
- I'm understanding this mentality now.
- It's not an illness, it's a self-own.
- I don't know. It seem
different in my head.
- I don't know about you,
I count food poisoning as an illness.
- Really?
- I do count food poisoning
as an illness.
- But then again,
I don't get sick often,
but I think I've only
ever gotten food poisoning
twice in my life.
- I didn't get it much
till I came to Japan.
I've had it many times in Japan, weirdly.
- Really?
- Yeah.
Like four, three times.
- I've never gotten
food poisoning in Japan.
- Yeah. I've never gotten
food poisoning in Japan,
I've got it, the worst
food poisoning I've gotten
was in China.
Also sometimes in
Thailand as well. I think.
- Yeah. I got really bad food
poisoning in the Philippines.
- Yeah. I think.
But I think food poisoning
in South-East Asia
is just part of the experience, right?
Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
- Exactly. It's
- Street food.
- Preventable.
- No. No.
In South-East Asia it is not preventable.
That shit is everywhere.
- [Crew Member] Yeah.
It's good the lights worked out.
When I went back to
it, I was like, "Damn."
- I never knew you could
food poisoning from a mango
but I definitely got it from a mango.
That shit fucked me up, dude.
- I swear to God, every
time Sydney has oysters
she gets fucking food poisoning,
and every fucking time she's like,
"Maybe this I won't. Maybe this time."
- It's so weird.
You hear every now and then
there's those foods that's like,
"Yeah. Food poisoning central."
Oysters being one of them.
- It's just poor storage.
- I've never gotten it from oysters.
It's so weird.
You've probably only eaten
oysters here in Japan, right?
- No. No.
Everywhere.
- Really?
- Yeah. I had it in the US, Australia.
Everywhere. And I've never gotten it.
- It's a gamble in the UK.
- Really?
- Yeah. It's very much a gamble in the UK.
And, I think, a lot of
places in the US as well.
Because it depends how well they store it,
or how fresh it is.
- It's human error. See?
This is why I don't count
it the same, in my head.
(laughing)
If somebody sneezes at
me in public, I'm like,
"It can't be helped."
Or "Whatever. Whatever"
- Face mask.
- If somebody forgot
to fucking freeze a piece of
fish, then serve it to me,
someone fucked up and made me sick.
- Wait. How is someone sneezing
on you not a human error?
- Well, no. You get it,
Let's say you're in a plane,
someone four seats behind
you sneezes, whatever,
they didn't react quick enough.
I feel like that's not,
I can't possibly-
- They didn't react quick enough?
- I couldn't then go to court and be like,
"This person sneezed
on the plain behind me
and didn't cover up their face."
I feel like you can't
hold someone accountable.
Whereas, let's say somebody just didn't
store a piece of fish properly,
that's negligence on their part,
and then they served it to you.
- Yeah. I get that.
- That's why
I don't treat it the same.
- I don't treat it the same either
but it's still an illness.
- Regardless if it can be
helped, or it cant be helped,
it's still an illness.
- That's why I feel like,
Because it's not a way to-
- Okay. Would you count
cancer as an illness then?
- You don't get cancer from eating fish.
- No. No
No. What I'm saying is,
is you treat it completely differently
but it's still an illness.
- Yeah.
But that's something you can just get.
That's just different.
Most of the time-
- lung cancer?
- Yeah, yeah.
What if you smoke enough,
that's, technically,
human error.
- Yeah. But that's on you.
That's on you.
(laughing)
- So then in that case,
it wouldn't be an illness,
according to you.
- But even then, stuff like that,
it's like it only raises your chances,
whereas if somebody just
gives you, flat out,
a completely fucked up
piece of fish or meat
that has been stored improperly,
you're going to get sick 100%.
Whereas there are people
who've been chain smoking
from age 10 till 100 who don't get it.
So it's complete luck on that part.
But with the storage, food and all that,
that's like, "All right.
Somebody fucked up."
You know what I mean?
That's categorically,
someone just fucked up
and they gave it to you,
and poisoned you.
That's what it is.
It's different to getting an illness.
It's totally different.
Doctors in the comments
are cracking up right now
- I bet.
- on this conversation.
(crew member speaks indistinctly)
- I actually wanna know what
people think about this.
I feel like I'm not the
only one who thinks this way
towards food poisoning.
This is not a weird thing.
- It's just you getting ill.
That's just it.
- But if you ask me
how often do I get ill,
I wouldn't count that because
that's got nothing to do with-
- It's an illness.
- No, it's not.
- You're literally sick.
- If I were to just make myself vomit,
would you say that I've gotten an illness?
- No.
- Well then why would food
poisoning count towards that.?
- Because it's a literal disease.
- But that's got no comment
to how often you get ill,
that's how often you eat bad shit.
- No.
- Yeah.
It's entirely different.
- No.
I mean, it all depends
on your environment,
but obviously if you
are in an environment,
where a lot of people are ill
or are going through a wave of illness,
then you're more like to get ill.
In the same way, if you
live in an environment,
where people are less careful
with their food preparation,
then you're more like to get ill.
That is a thing.
If you go to South-East Asia
or a lot of places where the
food standards aren't as high,
It's true. It's true.
- Yeah. No, it's true.
I'm not throwing shade,
I'm just saying facts here.
Okay, guys?
I'm saying facts here.
You go to a fucking street
vendor on the street,
your just like, "How
was this meat prepared?
Where did this meat come from?"
They don't fucking know.
- "From the back of my truck."
- Exactly. Exactly.
I mean, it's all risk.
It's all risk at the end of the day.
You can eat raw chicken in Japan,
and apparently here it's more safer
because food standards
here in Japan are higher.
I don't know how true that
is, how not true it is,
but at the same time
you're still taking a risk.
- What if you're the problem?
- I could be the, I could be-
- What if your stomach's just weak?
- Well, no.
I mean, if the restaurant just gives me
poorly stored sausage, I
think that's their fault.
That's on them.
- Well, no.
Because the one thing I learned from,
when I was in the
Philippines, is that, yeah,
the food standards are
a lot lower than normal,
but people don't get sick
because they just naturally
have more of a resistant stomach
from living there.
- Well, not always.
- Yeah. I'd say that's true, actually.
I would say that's true.
- [Connor] Not with everything, though.
- Not with everything.
But with a lot of things that
visitors to those countries
would immediately get sick with.
- I wouldn't say I have a weak stomach.
I normally don't have a
problem with gross foods
or something that's a little off,
but I mean, there are times
where I've eaten something,
and then I've gotten really sick.
And I was like, "Why did I eat that?"
- Well, what do you count
as food poisoning then?
Because,
you go to a country or something-
- All right give me an example.
Throw things at me,
and I'll be like, "Food Poisoning or not."
(laughing)
- Okay.
You go to a country,
you taste something that your
body has never tasted before,
it's totally new cuisine
and your body's just like,
"ooh. Ooh.
- That's not food poisoning.
- "I don't like this."
And then you get the shits for five days.
- No. That's not food poisoning.
Shits isn't the food poisoning.
- If it comes back up, that's
food poisoning, normally,
in my mind.
- To me, It's like you need to have,
Your body is literally
physically reacting in some way,
where it gives you a fever
or a headache or vomiting.
- I never get,
- Something that's not normal.
- I never get anything
like that from eating food,
but when I do eat,
can normally remember what
it was that gave me it
because I very much felt rough
immediately after eating it.
- Yeah.
Because I count food
poisoning as I am conked out,
in bed because I-
- Throwing up.
- Yeah. I'm throwing up.
I've got a fever.
Because that is, It's literally
a bacterial infection.
- Yeah. I think if it makes
you feel a little queasy
and it gives you the
shits, no, that's not.
You do have a weak stomach for that.
But I think if you're
throwing up, you have a fever,
yeah, you have food poisoning.
That's what I would, But then I wouldn't,
In my mind, if that
happens to me, let's say I-
- You get that once a year?
- Lately, it's been more.
It's been two, three times.
- What the fuck?
- I've only had that a
few times in my life.
- I order a lot of food.
I never cook myself,
so I think it-
- Yeah. Same.
- Yeah. I don't know.
I think it happens a lot more.
Also-
- That's why I'm saying I think it's you.
(laughing)
- I think it's just you.
- No it's not. It's not me.
- I think that's a you problem.
- I'm not the one cooking it.
- I think you just have a weak stomach.
- No, no, no, no, no.
Because it's happened
where it's not just been me
who gets it from the food.
Other people have gotten
sick who were with me.
- Well, maybe they have
weak stomachs, too.
(laughing)
- No, that's not,
That is not a good,
"Your honor, why did
you give people E.coli?"
"Oh, they just got weak
stomachs, isn't it?
Just got weak-"
- They just need to get good.
- No. No.
No. That's not how it works.
(laughing)
Because out of the last three
times I got food poisoning,
two times it was sausage.
And I can distinctly
remember eating the sausage
and being like, "Hmm. Really
pink. Really, really pink.",
and I was like, "But I think
it's okay. I'll eat it."
And then I regretted it immediately after.
(laughing)
So I learned that.
And the other bag was,
The other one was from a
bag of Flamin' Hot Cheetos,
that was four months off.
- Well,-
- Well, That, again,
sounds like a you problem
- Well, yeah.
- So that's mine.
But when I, Okay, let's say I'm an idiot,
and I eat a four-month- old
bag of Flamin' Hot Cheetos,
to me, if I start throwing up,
that, in no way, in my mind,
is in the same category as,
Let's say I got tonsillitis or something.
Because this is me being a fucking idiot,
and then I immediately
got consequences for it.
The only difference is, let's
say I go out to a restaurant,
is that I didn't cook it but
somebody still fucked up.
Let's say the sausage was off,
so, in my head, it's
not in the same category
as getting an infection from just,
I don't know where the fuck I got it from.
Because it's, somebody fucked up.
With the Flamin' Hot Cheetos, I fucked up.
(laughing)
I massively fucked up.
- Yeah. All right.
Here's the thing.
You go to a convention.
You go to a convention,
you party everyday at the
convention, you get con flu.
Everyone gets fucking con flu.
A lot of people get fucking con flu.
- Of course.
- Does that count as the same thing?
Because you're going to
a place where you know
that you're probably going to
get infected with something
along the way
because there's a lot of
people in a single area
and you're putting yourself in a position
where your immune system
is going to be weaker
because you're naturally
doing a lot of shit.
Does that count as the same thing?
- [Joey] Is con flu an illness?
- Which category?
The food poisoning or-?
- Does con flu count as any one?
- Getting sick, normal sick.
- Getting normal sick?
- Yeah, normal.
That's not food poisoning.
I feel like food poisoning is
in its own complete category.
Closer to self poisoning to me.
(laughing)
(crew member speaks indistinctly)
in my head.
I don't know how, Do you
understand why I think that way,
or is it you just don't get it at all?
- I understand why you think that way.
- I understand, I just
don't agree with it.
- Because it's not like
I'm going to the con,
and I'm going around licking
floors, and I'm licking,
Do you know what I mean?
I am just, I know that
you're at a higher risk
because you're around a lot of people.
People who aren't showering,
people who aren't-
- Sometimes you shake a
hand and you're just like,
"Ooh. I better sanitize
it afterwards, man."
Sometimes you know, man.
Sometimes you know.
- My hand is getting sick.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And the kids were taking photos,
you're getting close to
people, people want you,
people touch you.
Yeah. I understand that
that's just a big risk.
Sometimes I get con
flu, sometimes I don't.
Again,
that's me almost squishing
six months of interacting
into one weekend.
So to me it makes sense that
there is a very high chance
that you can get a sickness.
But again, it's not the
same with food poisoning.
Because, again, somebody had to fuck up.
(chuckles)
In my head.
I wonder if I'm the only,
I can't be the only person
who sees it this way.
There must be a lot of people
in the comments who are-
- I mean, you're the first, in my head.
- Really?
- You're the first person.
- But how many people have
you discussed this with?
This is not a normal thing to discus.
- Well, yeah.
It's not a normal thing to discus
because I think for most people
food poisoning is an illness.
There's no question about it.
- If you asked me,
"Connor, what's up? Why can't
you come in to record today?"
I'm not going to be like,
"I've been poisoned."
I'd be like, "No. I got sick. I got sick."
But in my head, I would
have this category,
that I would label it.
It just happens that now
we have to talk about it,
and I'm explaining it,
and I didn't realize that
people didn't see it this way.
- So the next time you get food poisoning
and you say, "Oh, sorry guys. I'm sick.",
I'm allowed to call you out on that, or?
- Yeah. You can be like, "Who fucked up?"
Yeah.
- Who fucked up.
- I'll be like, "Did you
eat another fucking bag
of Flamin' Hot Cheetos, Connor?"
- Was it you or was it
the restaurant this time?
Who was it? Who's the culprit?
- Here's the thing.
If I get sick from a restaurant,
and you only know me, it's
like, "Oh, Connor, you."
You don't know, Let's say
this restaurant's poisoned
100 other people, then you
would start being like,
"What the fuck is going on?
Why is this restaurant still open?"
The only difference is
you only hear my side.
But obviously, normally a
restaurant wouldn't be doing that.
But still.
I'm not crazy. This is just,
it's perception.
I sound like Alex fucking Jones.
"Turn the frogs gay with the water.
You're just hearing
one side of the story."
- No. No.
I agree that food poisoning-
- It's just very hard to argue
without sounding fucking insane.
- I agree that food poisoning
is in a different category
than, let's say, the flu or tonsillitis,
but I would say that there
are a lot of illnesses
that exists that can exist
in different categories,
from the flu and food poisoning.
A lot of things.
But at the end of the day,
in my mind,
- You count all-
- They're all illnesses.
- Yeah.
But if you asked me,
"Connor, are you sick?"
I'd be like, "Yes."
If I have both.
But in my head, I don't
treat them the same way.
- There are millions
of different illnesses,
with millions of different
ways to prevent it.
To stop yourself from getting ill.
All this kind of fucking shit.
- I want to bear mind,
that this is not some hard,
scientific definition I put in my head.
This is just a mentality I
have towards thinking about it.
- Don't worry.
People don't come to "Trash
Taste" for that shit.
- I know.
But there's always some of
these comments being like,
"I've got to poke some holes
through Connor's thoughts."
And it's like, "Well, yeah.
Because I didn't really think
that much about it anyway.
- He's just talking out of his arse.
- It's just a rough
estimation of how I view it.
- I just don't see the benefit
in labeling food poisoning
as a different thing.
- I know.
- I feel like that's more of
copium on your end, to me.
I'm not ill. I'm not ill.
- Why not just say they're all illnesses?
- I don't know.
Again, this isn't something
that I ever discuss with people.
This is not something that
comes out in the open often.
Obviously, now I'm having to talk about it
in front of a million plus people.
That was not my intention.
This is just a soft definition in my head
towards how I viewed the illness.
- This episode is sponsored
by Honkai Impact, 3rd.
With a girl in both black and white,
let's welcome Schicksal's
strongest Valkyrie,
Bianca Atasioner.
- [Connor] The most
awesome one in version 5.5
must be the Durandal,
who is the first Valkyrie to
have black and white forms.
Just look at her costume,
and we would know that
she's a cruel beauty.
- Specially designed for Durandal,
the new battlesuite, Palitinus Equinox,
is also available in
two alternative forms.
They are Knight and
Guardian, respectively.
The switch itself has skill effects, too.
It's like owning two battlesuits, guys.
- [Joey] In additions
to the new characters
and battlesuites, "Honkai Impact, 3rd"
also prepared four new
outfits for two Valyries.
What's more exciting, if you
get one outfit of the Valkyrie,
you can unlock the
other one automatically.
They're just giving them away.
- Since version 5.5 is also designed
for celebrating he anniversary
of the global server,
logging in rewards a
"Fourth Anniversary" emblem.
Not to mention a variety
of upgrade materials,
a large some of cards and crystals,
the spring event also rewards
a new S-Rank battlesuit,
Spina Stera.
And an S-Rank battlesuit
option, S-Rank battlesuit X-2.
Surprises are also delivered
outside of the game.
Lot's of captains have
well prepared fan art works
from the "GLB, Fourth Anniversary",
it will be released on
the 26th of February.
Come and join the Honkai Carnaval.
More excitement can be found there.
- So, what are you waiting for?
Download "Honkai Impact, 3rd" today,
and use the gift code on
screen for a bunch of freebies.
The rewards are 30 crystals, 2888 Astride
and a Hersche trial card.
- Thank you to "Honkai Impact, 3rd"
for sponsoring this episode.
Back to the show.
- Okay.
But, obviously, if you're like, "E.coli",
I wouldn't count that the same
as regular food poisoning,
because that's-
- Bringing this back to how
we started this conversation,
- How did this even come up.
I don't even remember.
- How often
do you normally get ill?
- That's how it started. There we go.
- Not counting food
poisoning, once a year, maybe.
- Okay.
Including food poisoning?
- That's exponential.
I don't know
(laughing)
That could be four, five-
- How many Flamin' Hot Cheetos
is that eaten in a year?
- How risky we talking?
How risky was my,
Well, last year it was four.
Four times, I think.
- Jesus.
- Three of them were
food poisoning, though,
so one.
(laughing)
One.
- So aside from this time,
the last time I got ill,
was literally two years before this.
- I don't get ill often.
Very rarely.
- I very rarely get ill as well.
I very rarely get ill to
the point where I cannot,
I cannot work.
- Function.
- I need to actually take
a rest and take a break.
Because I feel like, I don't
know, I feel like my body,
Obviously, this is all talking bullshit,
I feel like body, even if-
- [Connor] This whole episode is bullshit.
- Yeah.
Because there's been points
where Sydney has been
fucking conked out in bed
with a high fever and all that shit,
and I get a mild cough.
And that's just it.
And she's conked out for two days,
and I'm just like, (imitates coughing)
"How you doing, honey?
How you doing, honey?
- This is why,
- You need to get good.
- This is why hospitals scare me as well,
because when I'm around sick people,
- That's right. That's how this
whole conversation started.
- Yeah.
When I'm around sick people,
I get way more scared of being sick.
- Oh, yeah. Yeah, of course.
- It freaks me out.
- Of course. Yeah.
- I don't know why.
Is this a human reaction that we have?
That we're scared of sick people?
- I think it's pretty natural
to be afraid of a hospital.
- Yeah.
I feel like that's a
natural human reaction,
- Because people die
in a hospital.
- because you are averse to getting ill.
You are averse to getting ill.
- People are sick. People die there.
Why would you enjoy a
place where people die?
- Back when I got, Back when I had it?
I mean, it's genetic, what
the fuck am I talking about?
I still have it.
It's cute. That's cute.
I'm cute.
- Even if it is, it's just state of mind.
- Just (grunts) that shit away.
It's gone. Boom.
Just like that.
- [Garnt] It's like food poisoning.
(laughing)
Preventable.
- I just got my five step course
on how to get rid of any genetic illness.
I had to go to the hospital
a lot when I was a kid,
because I had to get my blood
tested every three months
or something.
Or every six months. Something like that.
Anyhoo, far too often, for my liking.
And I hated it because I had
to sit there for four hours,
get a test, wait, get another test,
and get results and stuff,
and then the whole time
I was just surrounded
by very, very ill people.
And it was always just really
scary as an eight-year-old.
Then I keep growing up
and just kep seeing this,
I'm like,. "Uh-oh, uh-oh, oh-oh."
And all the offices the doctors have
are always really
cluttered, are really messy,
and I was always like, (grunts)
- I think the one thing I hate
about the hospital the most
is the smell.
- Yeah. The smell is pretty bad.
- The smell of a hospital is just,
It's hard to explain what that is.
- Yeah. There was also-
- It smells of illness.
(Joey laughing)
Literally.
Like I said, when you're
ill, and when I was ill,
things just smell and taste different
- Yeah. Of course.
- Naturally.
And it fucking sucks.
But when you go to a
hospital, for some reason,
you get that same smell
where it's just like,
"Man, everything just smells stale."
- [Joey] Yeah. It's stale
That's the word. Yeah.
- It's the stale smell.
Like the magic, the color has
been taken out of everything.
(laughing)
That's how I feel when I'm ill.
I don't know.
It just feels like life gets
a black and white filter
being put onto it.
- [Joey] Do you like the
smell of the dentist?
- No.
- Because I know people who
love the smell of the dentist.
- What is the smell of the dentist,
Swinging Tod?
What the fuck?
(laughing)
- It's like the smell
of, I don't know what it,
it's the smell of,
How do you describe the
smell of the dentist?
- I don't go,
Brah, I'm British. We
don't go to the dentist.
- Oh, yeah. True.
(laughing)
- I don't know. I don't
smell the dentist often.
I'm just in and out.
I want to get out there
as soon as possible.
- It's smells like clean teeth,
but in the worst way possible.
It smells like chemicals.
That's the only way.
- Yeah. I guess so.
I never really thought about it.
It smells like hand sanitizer.
That fresh-
- All medical places
smells like a sterilized-
- Yeah. It smells clean
but not in a good way.
- Really?
- Yeah.
Because when you think of,
say, something that's clean,
like scented hand sanitizer, whatever,
or Febreze or whatever,
Usually it's like, "Oh,
that's a good smell."
That's a refreshing smell.
But hospitals and dentists,
for me, I just like,
"It's clean but something's wrong."
- No. Hospital and dentist
smell different to me.
- No, no. They smell different,
- Very, very different, for me.
- But I feel their in the
same category of it's clean,
but it's not a good clean.
It's too clean.
Where it's like, "Nothing's
here anymore.", levels of clean.
Sterilized is a good word.
- So it's sterile,
which I hope they are.
I would very much hope
that they are sterile.
(crew member speaks indistinctly)
- [Ashley] Apparently, the
dentist smell of clove oil
and tooth dust.
- Clove oil and tooth dust?
What the fuck's tooth dust?
- What the fuck is tooth...
(crew member speaks indistinctly)
- Literally the dust.
- Gross.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, what?
- [Ashley] Disinfected
in formaldehyde as well.
- Yeah. It just smells like chlorine.
- No.
- It has a feint chlorine smell to me.
- Maybe the dentist I go to.
I don't know if it it's-
- [Garnt] What were they
shoving in your mouth, Joe?
(speech drowned out by chatter)
- I don't know if they're
next to a pool or whatever,
but it smells like chlorine.
- How often do you guys go to the dentist?
- I try to go twice a year.
Just as a check up.
- When it hurts.
- I think they say...
- Do you put it in your,
Because British culture,
British culture.
We don't go to the dentist a lot.
And I only really started going,
Actually I would normally
only go to the dentist before,
when I'd go to Asia,
because dentist were
actually really much cheaper.
- I am before all the British tooth jokes
in the comments now.
- Do you have a schedule of,
"Oh, it's been three months,
or six months or
something", to the dentist"
- My dentist emailed me.
He was like, "Where are you?"
- Yeah.
I think the say, when you're an adult,
you should go, at least,
two or three times a year.
As for a check up.
- I don't fucking know.
- The good thing with the dentist,
is that even if you don't have a cavity
or you're not hurting anywhere,
they'll at least just fucking
clean your teeth for you.
- Fuck. I hated them
cleaning my teeth though.
Why was that drill so loud?
- The water pressure thing?
(imitates drill)
- In Japan, it's horrible.
- To me, I think the worst
feeling is getting a filling.
I don't know-
- Have you got a filling before?
- Huh?
I've gotten one before.
And, I don't know, that
experience as a kid
just scarred me for life.
I don't know what it is about
just hearing the drill and
just not being able to see
what they are doing to your mouth.
- Do you want to, Do you want to see?
Do you want a T.V?
- I don't know.
I don't know what's scarier because-
- I need to see this in 4K.
I think it can be arranged, actually.
- No.
It's that feeling of when
they hit your nerve ending
for just a second.
- [Co- Host] Ow.
- I feel that in my nightmares.
Ever since I felt that
as a kid the first time,
that put me off going to
the dentist ever again.
- The worst, for me, is when
you hear the drill sound
but it's deep in your ear,
so it sounds like it's in your ear.
I hate it because it just sounds like
someone's just getting
into your ear, like that.
- I had a night mold made.
When you go to bed, you wear
one of those plastic guards.
- Yeah. I've got that as well.
- Yeah. I've got that.
- I haven't worn it though,
so that's good.
- You haven't worn it?
- Nah. I forgot to.
- Dentist will be proud of that.
- I know. Sorry, dentist.
Fuck.
My dentist speaks English, too. Fuck.
I don't know. It was really
annoying to sleep with
for a long time.
I couldn't sleep with it in.
It was very uncomfortable.
- Yeah. It took me about
a week to get used to.
- I woke up drooling everywhere with it.
- Yeah. Yeah.
That's a normal experience. Yeah.
- That happens. That happens.
- I think I didn't start snoring
until I started wearing my mouth guard,
because it literally force
you to be a mouth breather
when you sleep.
Because you got the gap between your teeth
- It pushed my, I couldn't
breath comfortably.
- [Garnt] Why did you need to get it?
- I don't know.
My dentist was like, "You
don't really need it,
but it's good to just prevent-
- Dentist was just
trying to fuck you over.
- It was 300 bucks.
I'm sure they were like, "Yeah,-
- "Yeah, you definitely need this."
- [Garnt] You need this. You need this.
- They were like, "Yeah, I do,
grinding your teeth isn't
an issue, but it might,
so we can get a night guard done
if you just want to be careful."
And I was like, "Oh, sure."
And then they did it,
and then I just really didn't like it,
so I just stopped using it.
- Because I grind my teeth as well,
but my doctor was like, "If
you don't have this guard,
your bottom teeth are
literally going to disappear."
I was like, "Oh."
- I really grinded my teeth.
- "Please give me the mouth guard."
- I didn't really know about it
until I started getting jaw problems.
I think in my mid twenties, I
started getting jaw problems,
where it felt like my,
Sometimes I'd wake up and
something will feel off,
or slightly dislocated or something.
- God.
- I didn't know that it was an issue
until I started getting the issue.
And then I went to my dentist
and you're like, "Yeah.
You grind your teeth a fuck ton.
You need to wear a mouth guard
because your bite is going to
get more and more deformed.
- Well, after this episode,
I'm going to schedule an appointment,
because I forgot to reply to
that email two months ago.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I should probably go, too.
- But I hated it.
When they did the mold
thing, they put all that-
- [Garnt] That gunk in you.
- The putty thing.
- It was so confusing
figuring out how to breath
for a second.
Where I was like, "Wait, shit.
My mouth is completely
covered with this gunk.
How do I breath without my teeth?
It feels so weird.
- I wonder if that's how it
feel when you have dentures.
I don't know.
Just not having teeth,
it felt really strange.
Also, I remember they were
like, "Whatever you do,
do not swallow right now."
And then I've never had an urge
to swallow more in my life.
- Is that a challenge?
- It was like (grunts)
They're blasting shit in your mouth,
trying to clean it, saying that.
"Do not swallow. Do not swallow."
I'm like, "fuck it. Now
all I can think about
is swallowing this weird
liquid that smells like apples.
I want to do it."
- Joe-Joe fans being like,
(laughing)
- That's the joke or fact?
He thinks I wouldn't swallow
but I will swallow the poison.
(laughing)
- Next thing you'll say
is, "Don't swallow."
(Garnt laughing)
- It's true. It's true.
- My God.
- It's awful. I don't like dentists.
I don think anyone like the dentist,
if they do, I don't trust them.
- I don't think anyone
likes the hospital as well.
- Some people do.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Who?
- Kids who want to play on the free PS2
that they have there.
- You talked about this, didn't you?
- That used to be me. I used to like it.
But then the GameCube
controls were robbed.
- I wish I went to your hospital
because my hospital didn't
have that shit at all.
- Have you guys ever had
to ride in an ambulance?
- No.
- Yeah. I did.
In Japan, actually.
- In Japan? Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
Because Ahki had a slight
accident at our last place,
and it was pretty bad,
so we had to call the hospital,
and I was riding the hospital,
Not riding the hospital,
riding the ambulance.
- Riding the hospital.
- I had to get an ambulance.
So I was riding the
ambulance late at night,
and because it was late at night,
the closest spital was closed,
makes no fucking sense.
You'd think hospitals
are open all the time.
So we had to go to the next furthest one.
So it was a 15, 20 minute ride.
And luckily, Ahki was okay.
She was calming down in the ambulance,
and it was so fucked
up because, in my head,
during that whole ambulance
ride, 95% of my brain was like,
" Oh, God. I hope Ahki's okay,
and she will be able to
get out of this fine."
And 5% of my brain was like,
"Oh, fuck. I'm in an ambulance."
(laughing)
Like, "Whoa. This is so cool.
I've never been in one before.
This is what it looks like? Oh, shit."
- I would just feel really bad.
I feel like I'm
inconveniencing these workers.
- Even though it's their job.
- My leg could be broken,
I'm like, "Oh, fuck.
I'm so sorry for wasting your time.
Surely someone else has a heart attack
or something you can go to.
I can get there myself. It's all right.
- That's called an Uber.
- [Garnt] Just call an Uber.
- Well, it's just, I remember
I was in the emergency room,
I've never been in that
room before, by the way,
but I was in the emergency room,
and this guys was just
holding onto his thumb.
I thought that was really fucking weird.
And he was really calm.
He was holding onto his thumb like this,
and I could see-
- What you mean, holding onto his thumb?
- He's thumb.
- He's thumb was falling off.
- His thumb, it had been cut off.
And he was holding onto it.
- [Joey] Oh, in his hand?
- He was holding onto his thumb,
- What?
- and he was really calm,
and they were talking to him, being like,
"Are you ready, Mr. Jones, to go to the,
And he was like, "Yeah,
yeah. It's all right.
We'll go.
I don't mind waiting a little bit."
Really weird.
It was really strange,
because I didn't realize
what he was doing at first
until I saw the bag of ice with it,
and then he had a bandage
going around like this,
and his hand was like this,
and he had bandage just going around.
- I just wanted him to be like,
"Are you ready, Mr. Jones?"
He'll be like, "Thumbs up. Haha."
- That's really weird.
It's like T.V shows in the UK,
just farmers who had their arm cut off,
and they're like, "Yeah. Whatever.
Whenever you're ready."
- I'd be fucking freaking out.
If there's one finger
you don't want to lose-
- That's the thing you don't want to do.
You don't want to freak out.
You want to be calm.
- Yeah. That's true.
- The more you panic, the
worse it is for everyone.
You have to calm yourself down.
But that's easier aid than done.
- Yeah.
I mean, obviously, I've
never been in that situation,
so it's hard to image how you
would react in that situation,
because you've never
been in that situation.
- Yeah. It's weird, really,
because when I've been in situations
where I feel like I have
to calm myself down,
afterwards I'm like, "Is that what,",
You see people freaking out,
are they trying to calm themselves down?
What's going through their head?
Is it just panic?
- [Garnt] What do you mean?
- Let's say, if I'm bleeding really badly,
which has happened a
few times or something,
and I have hemophilia,
my whole focus, when it's
happened, I remember distinctly,
is I'm literally focusing
on not freaking out.
That's all I'm doing.
I'm trying to keep it together.
I just think, I'm like, "Is
that what everyone does?"
I don't know because there's no way
to get into someone else's mind.
So I wonder,
has anything ever happened to you
where you're really scared
and you're freaking out?
- I've never had anything life threatening
or anything like that,
so I wouldn't know,
myself, how I would react.
But if I know how I react
with a lot of situations,
it's just, yeah, calm.
Calm.
- It's like trying to force yourself.
I don't know how the, I don't know how,
The human mind is pretty fucking weird.
I don't know.
- I'm the kind of guy who,
in stressful situations,
just say nothing.
I don't know.
Okay, this is going off tangent now,
but I don't physically react
when someone tries to jump scare me.
A lot of the times.
I remember, every time
there's a jump scare,
or anytime Sydney tries
to prank jump scare me,
she goes, "Ha.", like that or something,
when I come out the shower or whatever,
and just completely like
fucking The Terminator,
zero reaction.
And she's just like, "Fuck you."
And I'm like, "Haha, Sydney. That's right,
I aint a pussy, bitch."
Whereas inside I'm just
like, "Fuck my life."
Inside, I'm screaming my
fucking heat out, man.
I don't know.
- Pee slowly runs down your leg.
(laughing)
It's like, "Get good, Sydney."
Aah.
(laughing)
- [Garnt] Yeah. So I don't know.
- I'm the complete opposite.
I hate it when someone
comes around the corner
and scares me.
I always stop myself
from throwing a fist out.
Because I'm like, "It's a
threat. Oh, no. It's not
It's not. Okay.
Thank God. (exhales sharply)"
- It's a threat.
- My fight or flight is just
like, "Fight. Oh, no, no, no.
Okay. I shouldn't.
I shouldn't."
But it's weird because when
I had to call the ambulance
for Ahki, I was surprisingly calm.
I thought I was going to be,
Because I'd never called
the ambulance before.
Because I didn't know what
the fuck the procedure was.
So the first I was calling,
in my head I was like,
"Oh, God. What the fuck am I going to say?
Am I going to stutter?
What the hell's going to happen?"
But then by the time I
got finished, I was like,
"Oh, I was a lot calmer
than I thought I was being."
- "Domino's will be here
in 15 minutes, honey.
Don't worry about it."
"Oh, can you call the ambulance now?"
"Oh, shit."
- Yeah.
- "Oh, fuck"
Sorry.
- "Oh, you said ambulance.
- "Oh, shit."
I thought you said peperoni."
- "Don't worry, Ahki.
The double peperoni pizza is
going to be here in 15 minutes"
- "You have something,
- "Oh, shit."
- You have something to look forward to.
Don't worry."
- "Fuck."
"Fuck."
- "Who's going to get here faster?
The Domino's delivery
guy or the ambulance?"
My bet's on the Domino's.
(laughing)
Yeah, no. It was surprisingly calming,
but then I think it was, for
me, I'm calm in the moment
but then, when it's all over,
that's when it all comes out.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
To me, I panic post, when
everything just sinks in,
to be like, "Holy shit.
That fucking happened.",
and, "I went through all this shit."
And it's only after
the even has transpired
that it actually starts to sink in,
and I start to feel the gravity
of everything that's happened.
At least to me.
I do have a question, though,
because I remembered this
in the experience I had in the past week.
Have you guys ever gotten fever dreams?
- What do you mean by fever dreams?
Can you define one for me?
- That's the dream you
have when you have a fever.
- When you have a really bad fever
and you start dreaming really weird shit.
Because I thought it was just a saying.
I thought it was just a term or phrase
until I started dating Sydney,
who gets some of the most
fucking weirdest fever dreams
I've ever heard in my life.
- While conscious or while asleep?
- What do you mean by,
What? She's just fucking waving?
"I'm having a fever dream."
- She's running around the
apartment or is she asleep,
wakes up and then she's like,
"Garnt, you won't
believe this dream I had.
I was the president."
- I don't think that's a fever dream.
I think that's just going psycho.
- Can we get a definition of
where fever dreams comes from?
- Okay. So when you have,
When you have a really bad
fever, obviously you try to rest.
Your body tries to rest.
Well, at least some
people's body tries to rest.
And then you go to sleep
and you're sweating.
You start having a really bad fever,
as your body tries to
fight off this illness,
and then some people,
I'm saying some people
because the only experience
I've seen it happen to
is with Sydney,
and she'll just wake up,
drenched full of sweat,
and was just like, "Honey, I
just saw Connor in a bikini,
running on the beach.
What the fuck is going on?
Where am I right now?"
She will say it.
She will just wake up and
say the weirdest fucking shit
that happened.
And I'm like, "What just happened?"
And she goes, "Oh, it
was just a fever dream."
- That's believable, actually.
That is a possibility.
- That wasn't a fever dream,
that was just a video.
- That was an episode
of the cosplay series.
- Yeah.
Because I've never had a
single fever dream at all.
Actually, I rarely ever dream.
- The problem is, No, no.
It's not that you don't dream,
because I think I'm the exact same way,
whereas I don't remember 99% of my dreams.
And it's fucked up because it's,
Some mornings I wake up and I'm like,
"I remember having a really good dream."
And then as I am waking up
and I'm trying to remember
the dream again, I'm like,
"Yeah, and it's, wait,
what the fuck did I just dream about?"
And it's so weird because
it literally fades away
as I'm trying to think about it.
But all I remember is
that I had a good dream,
but if you told me to
recite it, I'll be like,
"I don't know. I don't remember."
- Because, to me, I feel like
I just rarely ever dream.
I don't know.
Because if I have a dream-
- No, you do dream.
Everyone dreams.
- I'm sure I do.
(laughing)
I'm sure I do.
- You're not a fucking reptile.
You do dream.
- Maybe I am, Joey. Maybe I am.
- Do we have the definition
of a fever dream?
- [Ashley] Yeah.
Fever dreams are vivid, often
bizarre or unpleasant dreams
sleepers can experience
when they have a fever.
- I'm sure I've had a fever dream.
- [Ashley] Yeah.
They happen similar to the other dreams.
They can happen during any
stage of sleep, mostly-
- Yeah.
It just seems like her
dreams, when she has a fever,
is just the wildest ones.
- It's so strange, I
don't remember my dreams.
I very rarely remember them.
Maybe once every month.
I don't remember.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I probably can only
remember two nightmares I had.
- But if I have a dream,
I remember the fact that I had a dream.
But most nights, I wake up
and there was just a void in my head.
(Joey laughing)
There was nothing.
- Really?
- I dreamed nothing.
- Can you feel the sense of time passing
when you're aware that you're dreaming?
- Yeah. Have you ever had a lucid dream.
- No. I really want to though.
- Those are the funnest ones.
- I've only had it,
- I've had it once.
- I've only had it a few times.
- I think I've had situations where
what I wanted to happen in the
dream during it did happen,
but I feel like it's a battle.
I don't know.
This is so hard, to remember this stuff.
This is what scientists have
been trying to figure out
for hundreds of years.
I don't know.
- Have you ever had a
dream that's been so vivid
that it's just stuck with you for years,
and you can still recite it?
Because I don't remember
most of my dreams.
- You have?
- I have one nightmare
I had when I was little
that I think is the reason
why I'm afraid of heights now.
You know how they say you
can't die in your dream
because you've never
experienced it before.
- I think that that's BS.
- Well, actually, I
thought it was BS, too,
until I had this nightmare.
- I'm pretty sure I die
in a lot of my dreams.
- You all right?
- I don't know. I don't know.
Food poisoning.
(laughing)
- Call it a food poisoning dream.
- I've definitely died in my dreams,
but I've just woken up
immediately as I've died.
- Really? Do you always wake up?
Is that guaranteed?
I feel like I reset sometimes.
- I don't fucking know.
- Is it one of those,
"If you die in the
dream, you die for real?"
- You respawn in your dreams?
- I'm pretty sure I've
respawned in my dream.
I'm near certain I've
- The only nightmare I've had
that I can still vividly remember,
it was a really short dream
but I was flying in my room,
and then for some reason I
just stopped, and then I,
and then just stood-
- I just pictured a young Joe
flying in his room.
- Yeah. I'm just flying in my
room, like "Whee.", like that,
and then I just stop.
I remember I stopped,
and our house was, it was two stories
and we had the spiral staircase
that went down to the basement floor.
And I remember I just stopped
and I looked down at the spiral staircase
and I just dropped.
Head first.
And I vividly remember,
my face got about this
close to the ground,
and I woke up.
- And you woke up.
- Just shitting myself.
And I think from that point
on, I got afraid of heights.
Because I vividly remember
the feeling of falling,
and it was horrible.
- So you had a,
Your brain made a traumatic
experience for you?
- Yeah.
- That's so strange.
- To me, the one traumatic
dream that I've had
that has stuck with me for years was,
I remember this one time,
I was living this dream,
and I would wake up in my bed,
in my room that I was
living at at the time
and I would just go about my day.
And then it would just be a normal day,
and then something would happen
that would just be out of the ordinary.
I would see, I would see,
I would see a twin
followed by another twin,
like I just noticed a glitch
in the matrix or something,
and then as soon as I saw
that, the dream would reset,
and I'd wake up again.
And I would think that
I was in the real world,
and I would go about my day
and then I would notice
another glitch in reality.
It's fucking nightmare fuel
because I literally repeated this cycle,
and every time I would
get more and more paranoid
that I didn't know if
I was in a dream world
or if I was actually awake.
I was like, "Is this a dream world?"
Because I would go about my day,
and I remember the exact moment I woke up,
was about the 10th time, when
I went through an entire day
thinking, "Okay. I'm awake. I'm awake."
And I remember going to the toilet,
and I was getting ready for
bed and I looked at the mirror
and then my reflection turned.
My reflection turned away.
- What the fuck?
- I fucking freaked out,
and then I woke up for real.
For real, real.
- That's like an Ari Aster film.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- It sounds like a cool film.
- I woke up for real, real
and I was shitting myself
because I didn't believe the
fact that I was actually awake.
It literally fucked with my
mind for an entire few days.
Because I went about
those few days being like,
"Where's the glitch?
When's it going to happen?"
When's it going to happen?
- Where are thew twins?
- That's fucked up.
- That's scary.
- I don't know how my mind
created such a fucked up situation
that it literally fucked
up my mind in real life.
Maybe I'm still in the dream.
- Trash Taste is all a dream, baby.
- When you're dreaming, are you able,
You mentioned that you were flying,
when I'm in dreams and I'm like,
let's say I do something
that I know is impossible,
are you aware that you
know it's impossible
and that you're dreaming?
Because I often always get aware.
- I'm a ware that it's
impossible but I just,
Because lucid dreaming
is where you're aware
that what you're doing is impossible,
so you take full advantage of that.
- I thought lucid dreaming
was where you then controlled said dream.
- I can't control said,
- Oh, I know I'm in a
dream a lot of the time.
- Okay.
So I can't control my dream
when I'm in lucid dreaming state,
but it's more of, it's more of,
It's more like you've
realized that you're in GTA
with cheats on.
That's how I imagine it.
Because there have been
times where I'm just like,
"Oh, fuck. I'm fucking dreaming.
All right let me look. Am I dreaming?
Let me try flying.
Oh, I'm flying now. Brilliant.
I'm fucking dreaming. This is amazing."
- To me, that sounds
like you have cheats on.
See? I can't,
Because I don't have
dreams often but when I do,
at some point in the dream, I
figure out, this is a dream.
Like Inception.
- I turn those cheats on.
- This is Inception. This is Inception.
Something will happen that
my brain chose to make happen
but I also am aware that
that is not possible,
and that I am now aware
that I am in a dream,
but it doesn't change how I behave.
I know that I'm in a dream
but I still go on the dream.
This is so strange. What's
wrong with our brains?
- I don't know.
- Why are we so fucking weird?
I had this dream recently,
I cant remember the full,
I told the dream on stream.
It was something like I was in a situation
where I'd been falsely accused
of stealing this game cartridge.
I was then arrested for it.
And I was like," No, I'm not
getting arrested for this.
I didn't steal it. I refuse."
Ten I killed one of the cops and ran away
because he was trying to arrest me
over a fucking game cartridge.
And then it turned out into
this massive shootout and stuff.
Then I somehow kept getting away.
And then eventually I got caught
and then I went to prison.
And I understood I was in
the dream at this point,
So then, somehow, I
magically then got a phone,
it's like in Isikai.
I had this phone in prison
that I was then using to
then play games and stuff,
and have a normal life in prison.
And I don't know why.
Then my charger broke, and
I remember this happened,
and I was like, "Shit.
Well, my charger's broke."
And then I just skipped
and I had a charger.
And I was like, "Great. This is awesome.
- You skipped.
- This is awesome.
This is fantastic.
I just skipped.
I just skipped the part
where my brain had to think hard enough
to come up with the reason
why I needed the charger,
- It just appeared.
- and then it just went,
"Boop." I have the charger.
I'm like, "Oh, this is
great. This is amazing."
I don't understand why
this happens though.
- But did you realize it was a dream?
- [Connor] Yeah.
About half way through the dream
I understood it was a dream.
- But you don't take advantage of it?
- I don't know how to.
- I was about to say I
love how in the dream
you still got arrested.
He's taking an L in the dream.
- Yeah. This is my thing.
If it was my dream I wouldn't
go to fucking prison.
- Yeah. You wouldn't go to prison if you-
- Oh, shit. That's right.
And then I remember, No, no.
This is incorrect, actually,
I didn't get the charger,
I remember I got,
this is where I reset.
So I went to the roof of the prison
because I couldn't get
a charger so I thought,
"What's the fucking point
if I can't play games?",
I jumped off the roof of the prison,
and then I reset in the prison.
(laughing)
I died. I died.
And then I just, in my head,
I remember there was a jump,
I remember I died,
and then I just appeared
back in the prison again,
with the charged iPhone with
a new charger or something.
- It's like the worst
version of Age of Tomorrow.
(laughing)
- It's a terrible dream. Awful dream.
- Age of Tomorrow, Jail version.
- I just don't know
why this was happening.
Why?
I understood it was a dream,
why can't I have some control over it?
They're all shit dreams.
I always have shit dreams.
- But at least you remember-
Because to me, a lot of,
Say for example, last night,
to me it's like, "Okay.
I'm falling asleep.
Falling asleep. Falling asleep."
One second later, "Oh, it's 7 AM."
I feel no perception of time.
- Okay. When you wake up,
can you feel the time
without looking at the clock?
- Yeah. Sometimes, yeah.
- Yes, but not accurately.
- I feel like I'm pretty
fucking good at it now.
I don't know what happened.
I don't know if I'm
getting old now or what.
- It depends on how good my
sleep cycle is at that time.
Now it's a bit fucked up
because COVID just made me
want to sleep all the time.
So I'm just like, "Okay,
now I can't tell."
Because my body's constantly tired,
but before then I would be,
Sometimes you wake up and you're like,
"It's going to be 15 minutes
before the alarm goes off."
And then you look at the time,
- That happens every time.
- And you look at the time,
you're like, "I'm a fucking genius"
- Okay. Okay
The reason why I asked, do you know that,
is because I was, if I
asked in your dreams,
do you know that there is a
flow of time in your dreams?
- No.
- No, no.
- See? This is weird.
I know how much time is
passing in the dream,
in the real world.
Isn't this weird?
How strange is that?
(laughing)
- That's against Inception rules, though,
because we all,
We all know time passes
slow in the dream world.
- Yeah. Exactly.
- Because I wake up
after a dream or whatever,
and it'll be 5 AM and then I'll be like,
"I liked that dream, I'm also
going to go back to bed."
And then I know, when I'm in the dream,
how much time is passing,
because when I wake up,
the exact amount of time
that I thought had passed in the dream,
had passed in real life.
Isn't this so strange?
- But I think that's
just your subconscious
counting the time.
- Maybe.
- It's also like an alternate reality.
- Do you ever have a-
- Who needs VR?
Fuck them. Come in my brain.
- I am VR.
- We all had VR in our minds, bruh.
In our minds.
- This is one of the strangest
episodes we've ever done.
This is obviously the weirdest
topic we ever spoke about.
- Do you ever have a really fun dream
and then you get actively
pissed off when you wake up?
- Yeah. (laughing)
- Yeah. Of course.
- Oh, my God.
I remember some of the
funnest lucid dreams I had,
and the fucking Sydney wakes
up and is like, "Garnt, Garnt.
Let's cuddle.",
and I'm just like, "Fuck off,
Sydney. I'm flying right now.
I'm flying, Sydney."
- "I was on episode 24 and I
was the protagonist, Sydney.
I'm supposed to get what I deserve."
- The worst one for me is,
when I'm having a good dream,
because I don't remember
most of my good dreams,
but I remember I wake
up and I'm just like,
"Man, I don't remember what I just dreamed
but maybe if I go back to
sleep, I'll dream it again."
And so I go back to sleep
and I don't dream it again,
I was like, "No. It's gone forever."
- To me, there's a point,
Because, to me, I've had it before,
where I've had really, really fun dreams,
and you half wake up but before
your mind fully wakes up,
you're like, "Go back to sleep."
And then sometimes I've
been able to reinsert myself
into the matrix.
- I'm going in.
So I know sometimes I wake up, I'm like,
"If I go to sleep now, if
I go to sleep right now,
I can jack back in."
And then I get so sad
when I try to fucking
will myself to sleep.
Because you know
when you try to will yourself to sleep,
most of the time it doesn't fucking work.
But sometimes I just try
to will myself to sleep,
and five minutes passes I'm just like,
(sighs) "I'm awake now. Fuck my life.
This is the real world."
- I used to do that but I
don't ever try that anymore.
I think sometimes I'm
like, "Yeah. Whatever.
Just get on with it."
- "I'll just dream it
again tomorrow night."
- Just dream it again.
- Well, do you have a theme
to most of your dreams?
Are your dreams,
Because they say that your dreams
are normally reoccurring.
They're similar events.
- No.
- No, not really, for me.
It's all over the place.
- I just die in a lot of my dreams.
(laughing)
Don't know what that says about me.
There could be some dream expert,
But even that.
You know how people are like-
- Dreamologist.
- "Yeah. The dreams, they,
Whatever you do in a dream,
there's a real meaning
to it in real life."
- Maybe.
- If you stressed out
then you'll dream about
your teeth falling out
and stuff like that?
- Something like that.
Where they think that every single thing
that you can dream of has
a real life counter part.
Emotionally or feeling.
- I'm sure there is to some extent,
but there's definitely-
- Probably too complex for us
- Yeah. Way to complex.
to be able to solve it
with modern science.
- Yeah. I get really high
concept dreams sometimes.
I told you the dream I just had,
but sometimes I just
dream and then I wake up
and I'm just like,
"That was a really cool
fucking film idea."
That was a really cool film idea.
- How Garnt gets his videos ideas.
- Basically.
I don't know.
It's so weird, I don't
know how my mind works,
because sometimes I'm just
like, "Damn, I dreamed that.
That was such a cool fucking idea.
What the fuck?
How the fuck did my mind
come up with that concept?
- What language do you dream in?
As being as all three of
us can speak two languages.
What language do you usually dream in?
- No. English.
- English for me.
I've rarely dreamed in Thai
unless it's when I'm living in Thailand,
and I'm using it more often.
- It's so weird.
90% of my dreams are in Japanese.
I don't know why.
- Okay. What language
do you think in, though?
- Depends.
- That's probably why.
That's probably why.
Because I don't normally think in Thai
but there's been points
where I've lived in Thailand
and then my thoughts
start getting jumbled up,
and I start thinking in a
different language as well,
which is,
How do you describe thinking
in a different language
to somebody who only speaks one language?
I don't know how to properly describe it.
- Thinking about how
you think is also weird.
Now I'm like, "I don't talk
to myself when I think.
I don't think so.
But maybe I do talk to
myself when I think.
I'm not sure."
- Some people can't, though.
Some people physically
can't think out in the air.
- Now that you're telling me
that I'm talking to
myself while I'm thinking,
now I'm doing it.
But I'm pretty sure I don't do it.
I think I just do things.
(laughing)
- I just do things.
- Yeah.
I don't think I talk to myself in my head.
I talk out loud if I talk.
- Yeah.
Because I remember
reading about deaf people
thinking in sign language,
and that blows my fucking mind.
I can't even come close
to conceptualizing it,
but I know it happens.
I know people do it.
It's so weird to me.
- This episode is
sponsored by Express VPN.
- [Connor] When you use the bathroom,
you always close the
door behind you, right?
- Of course.
- You don't want a random
passer by looking in on you.
- Ewe.
- So why would you let
people look in on you
when you go online?
Using the internet without Express VPN
is like going to the bathroom
and not closing the door.
- Did you know that your
internet service provider
knows every single website you visit?
And what's worse is that
they sell this information
to ad companies and tech giants,
who use your data to target you.
(screaming)
- Is that why there's milf's in my area?
- Well, the good thing
is, is that Express VPN
puts a stop to all of that.
It creates a secure, encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
so that your online activity
can't be seen by anyone.
- I use Express VPN on all of my devices.
It works on everything.
Phones, laptops, even routers,
so everyone who shares your wifi
can still be protected, even
if they don't have Express VPN.
- And the best part is using Express VPN
is as easy as closing the bathroom door.
You just fire up the
app, press one button,
and then you're protected.
- So if you're like me
and you believe your online
activity is your business,
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com/trashtaste today.
Use our exclusive link,
E-X-P-R-E-S-S VPN.com/trashtaste,
and you can get an extra
three moths for free.
- Back to the show.
(gibbers)
- I would love to be able
(X-Files theme song)
to turn on my lucid dreams.
If I had that fucking power.
That is literally,
- So it's not normal or you
to be aware you're in a dream.
- No.
- I didn't know that.
- That's not normal.
- Wait, are you always aware?
- Yeah. Most of the time.
I'd say 80% of the time
I know I'm in a dream.
- Oh, my God.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah.
- You're that kid in school
that aces the tests without studying.
(stammers)
- No, no, no.
Because he knows he's in a
dream but he can't control it.
- Yeah. I can't control it.
- Oh.
- That's like getting,
becoming a lucid dreamer
without having the fun part
of being a lucid dreamer.
- It's weird because I'm
aware I'm in a dream,
and I know that I can want things.
I know I feel that I want
the thing in the dream
but it doesn't always happen.
I don't know how that works.
- Have you ever had a super
power when you're in a dream?
- Yeah. Yeah.
Many times.
- Well, define super power.
- But then I die, normally.
(laughing)
- It's too much power
to handle for one man.
- Literally, in your own mind
you're playing on hard mode.
I didn't realize it was that possible.
- He gets all these super
powers and he's like,
"Guess I'll die."
- I'm trying to think,
It's like, "Yeah. I always know at some,
I'd say 80% of the time, I
feel that half way through,
or at some period in the dream,
I know that I'm dreaming,
because things don't add up in my head
when I'm in the dream.
It's weird because it feels
like I'm conscious in the dream,
so I know what's happening,
and I know that some things don't add up,
and I'm aware that I have the knowledge
from my normal human life,
and I have that in said dream,
so if somebody fucking
teleports behind me,
at some point, after that happens
X amount of times or something,
I'm aware then that this
is now not possible.
Or if I reset.
When I die and I would come back.
- What is this reset mechanics?
So much in your dream.
What is this?
- No, no, no.
It doesn't happen often
but when it has happened,
if I die but I'm still dreaming,
I immediately know that
now I'm in a dream.
Because I died.
- [Garnt] Because you died?
- And also, generally,
- "You can't reset real life"
- You know what's weird as well
- Must be in a dream.
- I don't know
if this is a strange thing
but when I'm in danger,
that's normally a good way that I know.
Because rarely in life
am I ever in danger,
in weird situations.
So being in danger is not a
normal emotion I ever feel,
so when I end up coming
across it in the dream,
if somebody's chasing me,
that's normally one really
weird way that I get in tune
with the fact that I'm in a dream.
- Yeah. Because I also
very rarely dream, for one,
but even more rare is
for me to get nightmares.
- I see all of mine are nearly nightmares.
I want to say, again, 80% are
probably in the bad things.
- How do you sleep at night?
- I don't mind.
You see? Okay, here's the thing.
When something bad's
happening to me in a dream,
because, again, I know it's a dream,
I feel these emotions
towards it but then I also,
because, again, I'm aware it's a dream,
I have this weird sense of,
"Well, let's just see what could happen."
Because I don't feel like
it has any impact on my-
- Right. Because there's no consequences.
- on my actual emotions
I'm aware that it isn't,
Is this strange?
- No, no, no.
- I feel like if you have
nightmares that often then-
- But that's the thing,
I don't wake up from a
nightmare being like, (grunts)
like in the movies, (grunts)
That's why I always
find that shit so dumb.
Because I'm looking for
a nightmare and I'm like-
- Well, that happens to me.
- What? No.
I wake up from a nightmare
I'm like, "Oh, get my phone."
- No. I wake up and,
If it's really bad nightmares,
which I've had every now and then,
I wake up in an actual sweat.
- I've had my entire life,
in every single aspect,
ruined in dreams before,
and waking up like,
"Oh, that's good. I'm feeling better now."
Because when I wake up I feel much better.
Because I'm like, "Oh, good. It's-"
- No, no, no.
Because I've had nightmares
where something bad has happened
and then you wake up
and you just have this
instant sigh of relief.
When you're like, "Oh, my God. Thank fuck.
I though my life was ruined.",
and it's like, "It's great.
It's fucking great right now."
- I'm comfy in this bed.
- It's all in, baby.
- I'm not in jail.
- I've had so many dreams
- I've got my charging cable.
It's all good.
- I think I've had a dream
where I've literally had to tell my mum
I'm about to go to jail.
(laughing)
- Yes, yes, yes. I've had that.
- You've had that as well?
- I've had that.
- Seeing her cry and break down
- That's cruel. That's cruel.
- was just the,
- I wake up and I'm just like,
"Why does my mind do this to me?"
That was the most
heartbreaking feeling I've had,
which is telling my mum
I'm about to go to jail,
and I remember her fucking
crying and breaking down,
and me feeling like a,
Me just feeling like the
worst human in the world.
I wake up and I'm just like,
"I've never loved my life
more than I have now.
I've never felt more fulfilled."
- I've never had that.
- So people in your world
have really depth emotional ability?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- See? That's weird,
because in mine it's like I'm
the only person who is aware
of how emotions work and
everyone seems to be robotic.
- So everyone's like
an NPC in your dreams?
- Kind of. Yeah.
The depth isn't there.
Even when my parents are in
the dream, the reason, again,
this is another weird things,
the thing that gives it away, though,
- The depth isn't there.
(laughing)
- The thing that normally makes me-
- Not enough world building.
- Clearly.
This is another thing,
where it wakes me, When I
feel like I become, again,
in tune into the dream,
that I know it's a dream,
is when people aren't acting
the way my brain knows they are.
But it's weird because my
brain is the one making this.
So why does my brain make
the people like this,
but then in the dream, my brain also,
It's like I'm playing
checkers against myself,
and I'm like, "Fantastic move, Connor.
You've figured out the plan."
(laughing)
You know what I mean?
It's like what is happening in my brain?
- Even when you sleep you're
just trying to beat yourself.
(laughing)
- I'm beating myself.
- You're literally creating,
You're literally creating
a game for you to beat
while you sleep.
- What is happening?
- The absolute state.
The absolute state of Connor dreams.
- It actually makes so much
sense because, I swear,
every one of my dreams
is like a Isikai to me.
(laughing)
I literally get transported
into my own fucking story,
in my own fucking world.
There's depth in the world building there.
There's some high concept
dreams that I remember.
Characters in my dram
actually act like characters in real life.
- Garnt's like, "Finally I can self-"
- Sometimes when I wake
up, and someone's done,
I remember one time I had a dream
where Sydney murdered my family,
(laughing)
and I remember waking up,
I remember waking up, just as I found her,
I woke up and I turned to
her with such fucking anger,
be like, "You bitch.
I can't believe you did
that to my mum and dad.
How dare you."
- "Better have a good reason.
You better start explaining."
- We were about to go to trial-
- I will see you in court.
(laughing)
- Because at the time,
the emotions felt so,
The emotions felt so real to me.
I don't know.
Sometimes when I wake up and
the dream isn't resolved,
I still have those
emotions fresh in my body,
and fresh in my mind, that
it's hard to sometimes
- That's so strange.
- Get rid of it.
- It's like those stereotypical,
the girlfriend dreams about
the boyfriend cheating
in the girlfriend's dream.
Wakes up, slaps the boyfriend.
It's like, "What the fuck? Who is she?"
It's like, "What the fuck are you on?"
- It's the exact same.
I've never understood that but now I do.
- I've never spoken
about my dreams in depth.
This is the first time
I'm thinking, "Oh, yeah.
Maybe my dreams are weird.
Maybe I'm the weird one."
- Yeah, that's probably it.
- I thought I didn't
remember much of my dreams
but now that I'm thinking about it,
maybe I do just remember a lot of,
Because I don't dream often,
but when I do dream, it's
like an event for me.
It's literally like watching a film.
It's great. It's great.
- This one's going into the memory bank.
- Also, sometimes I have dreams, that I,
at least can only remember,
that are very brief dreams.
30 seconds of a dream that I can remember,
and I've woken up.
The latest one I remembered
that I was cooking meat.
I don't remember why.
I didn't know I was in that dream either.
- It's the mystery meat.
- I just woke up,
and I was, Probably the thing
that gave me food poisoning.
I don't know.
(laughing)
I remember I was cooking meat and yeah.
- Do you get food poisoning
in your dreams as well?
- I haven't. I don't think I have.
I dint think I have.
That's another thing.
I don't think I ever
get sick in my dreams.
From all the ones I've remembered,
I don't think I've ever
gotten ill in a dream.
- I don't think I've ever
- Well, I mean, you've
gone one step above,
and you just straight
up die in your dream.
- I never die from,
It's never like a dream with
me on the bed and I'm...
I'm always getting stabbed,
getting thrown, getting shot.
- I mean, in your dream,
you should be in your peak performance.
- Imagination, go.
- Your peak form.
I think it would be pretty sad
if your imagination's just like,
"Nah, you're a frail mother fucker, boy.
You're a frail mother fucker.
In your dreams? Nah, you can't fly"
- "How many times would
you like to die tonight?"
- But it's weird.
I've had drams where other
people have been sick in them,
and I've been around, The whole dream
has been around this person
who is progressively getting more ill.
- And those dreams are really depressing.
Because, even though, again,
I'm aware that I'm in a dream,
I can't do anything to
help them, I feel like.
And I still feel sad
because seeing this dream sad
version that I've made up,
of them getting more
dead, is really saddening.
This is so strange.
This is really bizarre.
- I think one of-
- This is why Inception was so good.
- I think one of the
weirdest dreams I had,
which actually would be a cool concept,
is I remember one time, I woke up,
and for some reason,
I knew I was the second coming of Christ.
(laughing)
I knew I was-
- The chosen one.
- I knew I was the Messiah.
- I knew I was the Messiah,
but the problem is-
- I believe that's called
the sigma male, Christ.
- So the problem is, The problem is,
I knew I was the Messiah,
but for the life of me I could
not prove it to the world.
So I would try to go out,
- You sound like every crazy guy.
- So I would out and I
would perform miracles,
I would go out, I would walk
on water, and shit like this,
and I remember I would be
like, "Guys, I am the Messiah."
And everyone would be like,
"That's a magic trick.
Where's the mirrors at?
And it was just me getting
progressively more, more, more
and more anger.
I think I even went on Joe Rogan
at one point in this dream.
- "I am Jesus Christ. I am Jesus Christ."
- Be like, "I am Jesus Christ.",
and he goes, "Prove it then."
And I remember I-
- "I'll turn the frogs gay right now."
- And I remember I took my hand out,
and I just made fire in my hand.
And he's like, "That's not impressive.
I've seen magicians do
that. Do something real.
Do a real miracle."
- All I'm hearing is, the dream gotten
wasn't actually about you becoming a god,
it was that you're furious with
the current state of magic,
catching up to real life miracles.
- It was me thinking,
if there was an actual Messiah
that got born into our world,
how would they go about proving it?
What would they need,
- Do sorcery.
- That was just me-
- it's very hard
in the modern era,
because of special effects
and all this stuff.
- Well, now that you say that,
someone's going to make
a fucking Jesus Isikai.
Literally take that concept.
I'm Jesus and I was
reborn into this world.
- I remember waking up, I was just like,
"That's a really cool
concept." I'm glad my,
That was a cool concept.
- Jesus Isikai.
Fucking copyright that.
- Now that you've said it.
- Copyright that right now.
- Now that I've said it,
someone can go write a story about it.
I don't fucking know.
- Have you guys ever had sleep paralysis?
- Yes.
- One time. One time.
- I have literally seen
sleep paralysis demons.
- Have you?
- Yes I have.
- Okay. I've never seen.
- Wait, that's not a meme?
- Yeah. It's not a meme.
- I've never gotten to the demon part,
but I've definitely had it.
Because I didn't believe in
sleep paralysis until I got it.
- And it's so fucking
weird because it's like,
to explain what sleep is,
is basically you're awake
but your body's asleep,
essentially,-
- You mind's awake but your body,
So I believe when you go to sleep,
your body excretes a,
- Chremical.
- Your mind excretes,
a chremical,
Your mind excretes a chemical
that paralysis your body
while you're sleeping,
I believe.
- Something like that. Yeah.
- Sound like some Hunter Hunter shit.
- Yeah.
And so what sleep paralysis is
is that that chemical's
still in your body,
so you can't move
but your mind is still awake.
- Really?
- That doesn't sound right.
- Is that right, Ashley?
Can you Google that?
(Ashley speaks indistinctly)
- [Ashley] You're conscious
but you are not able to move.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I've only had it once in my life,
and I though this was nonsense before,
and it was like,
it was on Joey's couch.
- What? Really?
- Yeah.
- When was this?
- Just to say, I mean,
- I've never know that.
- Hadn't proven any concrete cause,
(Ashley speaks indistinctly)
- Demons.
- Your sister was there.
Your sister had come.
And I remember,
it was weird because they
were speaking about me
and I was trying to get up
to say hello, but I couldn't.
(laughing)
I was face-down on Joey's couch,
trying my best to wake up.
I was fully aware.
I couldn't open my eyes,
but I was fully awake,
and I couldn't move my arms or legs.
But it didn't feel like I was paralyzed,
it felt that even though I was
willing my body to wake up,
my arms and my legs, my
whole body wasn't listening.
- Your eyes were closed,
because when I had sleep
paralysis, my eyes were open.
- Oh. My eyes were closed.
I could feel, I was well
aware that I was awake,
and I was aware of everything
that was going on around me,
but I couldn't,
it just took a moment.
And I felt like there was a battle.
When I was telling myself to
wake up, it wasn't doing it.
It felt like I'm pulling a chainsaw chord.
(imitates chainsaw)
I could feel like I was
trying to get through
and it wasn't happening.
I didn't understand why.
And eventually I woke up.
- For me it was so fucked,
because I clearly just
remember opening my eyes,
looking around.
It was like five in the morning.
I saw the clock.
I was looking around.
- Your eyes were moving around?
- I was darting my eyes around,
and I'm like," Why can I
not talk or hear anything
or move my body?"
- That's so weird.
- It was so fucked.
- You couldn't hear anything?
- I couldn't hear anything either.
I couldn't hear anything.
I tried to open my mouth to say something
and my mouth just wouldn't move.
- See? This is one of those things
where I feel like it's
definitely the mind.
Like this is like a fucking, A glitch.
- Well, yeah.
What the fuck else do you think it is?
The demons?
- This is why I think,
it's a chemical, I'm like,
"I don't know though.
Because to me it just
sounds like a neuron fuck up
in your head, like you hear
the (imitates Windows shutdown)
It's restarting. It's
trying to figure out.
- So what happened?
Did you go back to sleep
after your sleep paralysis?
- No, no, no.
I woke up after 15, 10 minutes.
- Oh, I went back to sleep.
- Oh, because this was,
I'd had a full sleep,
and I was waking up,
and I woke up and I just
couldn't move my arms or legs
for a little bit.
It wasn't like a,
it wasn't like I was trying to
move it and it wasn't moving,
I could even figure out how to move it.
Really strange.
I don't understand how this works.
- So I remember the one
time I got sleep paralysis,
and I literally saw a
sleep paralysis demon.
- What? What did it look like?
- Okay. I call it a sleep paralysis demon.
It just look like a ghost.
So what happened is, I
was sleeping on my bed
and I remember not waking up immediately,
but I remember just opening my eyes a bit
and seeing this ghostly figure.
I was like, "What the fuck is that?"
Immediately I punched my eyes open
and I see this female figure
praying above me or something,
- Sydney.
(laughing)
- No. It wasn't Sydney.
- She was like, (grunts)
- No.
But it was literally this,
looked like a nun or something,
that was just praying above me.
And I start freaking out
because I'm just like,
"What the fuck? There is a
literal ghost floating above me
right now.
- How old were you?
- I was around 24.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah. So I wasn't young,
I was, yeah, around 24.
I remember my mind going
into fight or flight mode.
I start panicking.
Because obviously if you
see a fucking ghost floating
floating above you, you start panicking.
So I try to start moving my
fucking body to do something,
and I remember my body
just would not move.
It was a terrifying experience.
- [Connor] That's so strange.
- Yeah. It was a terrifying
fucking experience.
And I remember, it took
me about 10 minutes,
10 to 15 minutes for me
screaming at my body,
just like, "Aah. Go on.
Move. Move
You're going to die. You're going to die.
You're going to die now."
- This sounds like a dream.
- It wasn't a dream.
It felt like, No.
Because it felt like a dream
and not like a dream at the same time.
Because I was obviously in my
room but after 10, 15 minutes,
I actually, finally was able
to will my body to just sit up.
I remember I immediately sat up,
I looked up and I could see the figure
literally fading away as I sat up.
It was super, super fucking surreal.
That's why I'm just like,
"Oh, was that the fucking
sleep paralysis demon
that everyone fucking memes about?
You mean that thing actually exist?
What the fuck?
What the fuck? That's so weird.
- That's like some Persona shit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Maybe it was just my Stand.
I don't know.
(laughing)
I don't know, man.
- You just lost your Stand, Garnt.
You could've gotten a Stand.
(imitates anime character)
- Put a dick in my
mouth right now, please.
Please, I'm begging you.
- All right. Another question.
When you dream, do you
visually see your surroundings
the exact same way?
Because I don't-
- What do you mean?
- Okay. I'm seeing this right now.
I'm seeing the real world.
It's way fuzzier when I
see things in my dreams.
- Aah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's say I know there's a table there
but I can't give you the detail of it.
I know what everything is around me.
- You just know that object is there.
- Yeah. I know everything's around me,
but I can't visually see
everything that's happening.
Really strange. Do you have this as well?
- No. Mine's in fucking RTX, on 4K,
- See? That's so strange.
- 60 FPS, man.
- Mine's in a fish-eye lens.
- That's why for me,
- What?
- What the fuck is wrong with us?
- Sometimes it's so hard for
me to tell the difference
between when I'm dreaming
and when I'm awake
because my dreams are so vivid and so,
I don't know.
Like I said, they have
a lot of depth to them
that sometimes I wake up
and sometimes I immediately
know that I've just woken up,
and sometimes it takes me
a few moments to realize,
"Okay. I'm actually awake now.
This is the real world. I'm
not in dream world anymore."
- I think, for me, things that are fuzzy
is things that don't exist in reality.
If it's like a table for instance,
then I can clearly see that it's a table.
But if it's a fucking fairy,
then it will probably look fuzzy.
- Well, you know when
you're trying to remember
a moment that happened,
you have a picture of it in your head.
You don't have it in 4K,
RTX, the way that you saw it.
It's fuzzy.
You remember where
everything was, you think.
You know what I mean?
The way that you recall
things that happened,
it's like that, the way
I see stuff in dreams.
I don't see it perfectly.
If I'm focusing on this
table, I know Garnt's there,
for example, but I can't see Garnt.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Items that I'm aware that
are there in the dream,
I don't see them unless I'm
then paying attention to them.
- Yeah. Because then your
brain has to render out.
- Right. It's rendering.
It's rendering.
(laughing)
- Because you know it's there
but your brain's just like,
"I don't want to render
this out right now.
I know that Garnt's there, I
just don't want to render out."
- You got to upgrade you
brain's graphic card.
(laughing)
- I mean, it's true. It's true.
Because when I picture Garnt now,
I don't need to see that
Joe's in the corner of my eye
because it's in the corner of my eye.
But when I'm trying to
remember the whole picture,
in my head, when I'm in
the dream, it's like that.
When I can't-
- Your brain does a sequential rendering?
- Are you still running a 1060?
What's going on?
- My draw distance is low as possible.
(laughing)
When I'm walking up to the building,
it starts to come into frame.
It's a load of shit.
What a weird fucking, What a weird shit.
It's like that, though,
where the dream doesn't exist
unless I'm focusing on it in the dream.
- Have you ever had a
dream that's taken place
in somewhere that you're
very familiar with?
- All of my dreams are in
places that I've been to
in real life.
- See?
Most of the time my
dreams are in new places
that I'm not aware of.
- Really?
- I don't know what it is.
- I think my brain is capable
of coming up with new
locations in my dreams.
- What I think it is, I
think it's stitching together
things that I've seen
in passing or a picture.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And what I,
I can't visualize a lot of things
but I just know what's
happening and I have an idea.
It's really strange.
- A lot of my dreams are in my house.
They take place in my house.
- Really?
- That's strange.
I never have dreams in my house, ever.
- But all sorts of fucked
up shit happens in my house
that shouldn't happen in my house.
- Wait, wait. Which house?
Japan? Japan?
- The house that I'm currently in.
- Oh, the house-
- Okay.
When your dream start, I'm
sure it's not, credit sequence,
shot to do, Joey opens up, "Hey."
Do you just wake,
It's like, "Game start."
You just start in a weird ass location,
and you're like, "What
the fuck is going on?"
- No. It's always mid conversation.
- What?
- I never remember the start of my dreams.
- I'm just like, "Oh, wait.
Oh, I guess we're here
now.", kind of thing.
- I guess I only remember my dreams
when I realize I'm in a dream.
So I never remember how I get there.
- Yeah. I don't see the
PlayStation boot up logo.
(laughing)
it's just like, "Oh, I'm in the game."
- Just like, "Oh,
Dreamcast start. Brilliant.
Okay."
- It's almost weird because I
feel like when I'm dreaming,
I'm watching a video and
at some point in the video
I'll know that's me.
Does that make sense?
It's a series of events unfolding,
and I'm not necessarily
constantly in that brain
of the person experiencing it.
This is so strange.
This is really weird.
- Even stranger question,
have you ever dreamed in third person?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That, to me, is the
weirdest fucking dream
because for some reason, in my dream,
it makes sense that I'm
seeing myself in third person.
(laughing)
Even though I've never
experienced that in my life.
- That prison one, it was
weird because I remember,
this is going to sound so strange,
I remember shooting the guns,
but then I also remember watching me
after shooting the guns.
- So it flicks between
first and third person?
- And the weird thing is,
is that I then was able to
feel the emotions of both.
When doing the dream act
and then when watching
me do the dream act,
This is so, This is so,
I've never spoken about this before.
- I've never spoken
about his before either.
- Now that your talking,
Now that you're making
me think about this,
I'm realizing how weird
this sounds to say out loud.
This must sound so bizarre.
I don't know if anyone else is-
- I don't think a dream
conversation is going to be normal.
- I've never had a conversation
just about my dreams before with anyone.
- The best way I can describe how it is,
is, you know when you're playing Halo
and there's that theater mode,
where at just any point you
can just unclip from the camera
But I'm not choosing where the camera goes
but I'm seeing it from a perspective,
and I don't understand who's
or what it is occasionally.
- Yeah.
Sometimes I have amazing
cinematography in my dreams.
(laughing)
I don't know how.
- If only the YouTube videos could match.
(laughing)
- I don't know how it happens
but sometimes I'm in first person
and then I go to a new area or something
and I have this really-
- Area unlocked.
- A new area on the map or something
and my dream switches to
this establishing shot
of this new landscape that I'm in.
- Garnt's swamp.
- And I'm just,
And I remember thinking in the dream,
"Damn. That looks cool as fuck.",
and then I load back into
my character or something.
I don't know how to describe it.
It's so fucking weird.
- Wait, your dream has cut scenes?
Is that what you're saying?
(laughing)
This man's dreams
literally has cut scenes.
And when it's over he goes
back into first person.
Holy shit.
- I don't know why.
Sometimes I dream in games or-
- Your dream sounds like
a Kojima game, dude.
- Yeah. Sometimes I dream in games
and sometimes I dream in movies,
which is why it never makes sense to me
how I can possibly dream in third person,
and at the time it makes it makes sense.
Because you never see
yourself in third person.
- By third person, do
you mean like in a movie,
from a movie camera standpoint?
Or are we talking GTA, behind yourself?
- Sometimes both.
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think it's weird
really because, again,
I know that I'm in this situation
and I fully understand that it's a dream,
but I never, ever think
that this is wrong.
Because I'm in the moment
and it's what my mind is making up,
so it always feels natural
when I'm in this dream.
- For some reason, I'm just
fucking remembering this now,
talking to you, every time
I'm in an interrogation room,
it's never POV interrogation room,
it's always side,
- It's the interrogation shot?
- Yeah. It's always side view.
Like this is fucking JCS
Criminal investigations or something.
It's so weird.
I don't know why.
- That sound fun.
Anytime I have a conversation
in the interrogation room,
I'm always in third
person, I don't know why.
It always feels like I'm in
control of what I'm saying.
- I'm sure that's purely because
we've just consumed media
where they portray those things like that.
I'd be interested to see if another person
who has never scene an
interrogation scene in a movie,
how they would view that.
- Yeah.
Because I've never been in
an interrogation in my life.
So I guess it makes sense.
- I've also found,
that if I'm highly anxious about something
when going to bed, there's a 90% chance
my dream is going to be about that.
- Oh. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's only ever happened a few times,
and that's only ever happened
with homework and exams for me.
- I was playing that
Pogostuck game recently and,
- Did it give you nightmares?
- Yeah.
I had nightmares that I
was stuck in this game.
And that I couldn't
stop playing this game.
I couldn't beat it.
Because I was making, I
played it for eight hours
and I made no progress.
And then I went to bed,
all I could feel was me
playing the game in the dream,
and then I was playing it
and I couldn't get out.
It was horrible.
(laughing)
- That's a nightmare.
- That was a nightmare.
- That's a true nightmare.
- That was a horrible nightmare.
- That's a scarier
nightmare than you dying.
- The worst part was, I knew
that I was in a nightmare,
and I was getting more annoyed
because why am I wasting time
where I could be actually doing this?
But instead I'm in the nightmare,
stuck in a cycle playing
it in my nightmare.
What a weird thing to dream up.
- Do you ever have moments
where your dream is so intense
that you don't feel like
you've slept at all?
- Yeah.
I wake up more tired than
before I went to bed.
- No. I've never had that.
- Sometimes, because you go
on such an emotional journey
in this dream, or at least I do,
that I wake up just exhausted.
- So what do you do then?
Just get another eight hours?
- I don't. I get up.
I get up but sometimes I just feel
like I haven't slept at all,
just because I feel like
I was awake in my dreams,
so I really didn't sleep at all.
I don't know. It's really weird.
- The worst nightmares
I've had is I go to sleep,
obviously tired,
and I'm probably not even
in the right state of mind
before I go to bed,
hence the reason why I have the nightmare,
and then I have that nightmare.
I wake up in that fucking cold
sweat, like (breaths rapidly)
"Fuck."
I'm so tired after that but I
don't want to go back to bed.
I know if I close my eyes right now,
it's just going to be
like, "To be continued."
It's just going to happen again.
- Why is it where you have a fun dream,
you can never get back into the dream?
When you have a nightmare-
- The nightmares
are waiting for you.
- When you have a nightmare,
you go back to sleep,
you re enter the nightmare?
- Well, I think it's
putting stress and stuff.
It's probably a mental state.
- It just comes out from behind the tree.
- Like Freddy's like, "Hey, guy. Hey, boy.
Oh, you sleeping yet?
No?"
Yeah. I don't know why.
I find it so much easier
to re enter my nightmares
than to re enter my fun dreams.
- Can I get a round of applause, everyone?
(crew applauds)
Because this episode is
sponsored by Manscaped.
They've just launched their
Ultra Premium Collection.
Believe it or not, it's for
your not so private parts.
I'm talking about a
leveled up hygiene routine
with your favorite manly scent.
This is an all in one
skin and hair care kit
for the everyday man
and covers you from head to toe literally.
Manscaped is trusted below the waist,
now trust them with the rest of your body.
- [Garnt] We all know how essential
the Manscaped Lawn Mower
4.0 is for that precise trim
below the waist,
but now you can enhance your
perfect grooming routine,
with their Ultra Premium collection.
Connor, what does this include?
- I thought you'd never ask,
Garnt because it includes
Manscaped premium deodorant,
well, not for your balls.
- What?
- For your stinky armpit.
And don't forget their body wash,
which will lather you up
with their infused allovera
and sea salt shower gel.
- That sound so nice.
- [Connor] And the two in
one shampoo and conditioner
to clean your scalp, and finally,
a free gift, gentlemen.
(gasps)
A three pack set of lip balm
to keep those chappers feeling moist.
- That's four products plus a gift
inside the Ultra Premium collection.
What a score, guys.
- So get 20% off plus free shipping
by going to manscaped.com/trashtaste.
That's 20% off plus free shipping
at manscaped.com/trashtaste.
The power of attraction is now in a bottle
thanks to Manscaped.
- Dee's nuts.
(laughing)
- Back to the episode.
- Okay. So since we're on the dream topic,
do you guys sleep talk?
- Yeah, I sleep talk.
- Really?
- I don't think I sleep talk.
- I generally just,
this is going to sound
terrible, just screams.
- Are you serious?
- I shout in my dreams.
- It's probably every time you die, right?
(laughing)
- Oh, he died.
- You've been around me
when I've sleep talked.
- I've never heard you sleep talk.
I've heard you snore very heavily.
- It's not the same.
- I don't know if you're screaming
- Or just a loud cuddle snore.
- or snoring,
or if it was Chris fucking snoring.
(screams)
- Like that.
(laughing)
- Not that loud but like, (screams)
Like that.
- Really?
- Did you ever sleep talk
when you did your subathon
where you slept on stream?
- I muted the mic.
- Oh, you muted the mic.
- Just in case I was fighting that dragon
that can only be defeated by racism.
(laughing)
- I only ask
because Ahki has recently
started sleep talking a lot.
And I'm concerned because,
by sleep talk, she
randomly shouts out phrases
that just don't make sense
when you think about it
in a sequential manner.
Ahki is the kind of person
who, literally, head touches the pillow,
three seconds later she's snoring.
Instantly like that, which
I'm so fucking jealous of.
But then, now it's gotten to the point,
where three seconds after
the head hit's the pillow,
start snoring, five seconds
later she says a random thing.
And I thought, The first time she did it,
I thought she was joking,
because it happened in
the spa of 10 seconds.
So I just started laughing.
I remember her,
She's like, "All right. Good night.",
goes to sleep, starts snoring,
and then she just goes,
"legs"
(laughing)
I was like," What the fuck was that?"
- Maybe she was in one of Garnt's dreams,
she's reading the title card.
(laughing)
- Chapter 3. Legs.
- And then I started laughing,
and I was like, "Come on,
sweety. What are you doing?"
But she continues to snore.
And I was like, "Wait. Are you serious?"
And then she goes, "butt fries"
(laughing)
And so I had to shake her awake.
I was like, "Are you
fucking with me right now?"
And she wakes up and she's
like, "What time is it?"
I was like, "It's been 20
seconds. What are you on?"
Because in her head it's
like an hour has passed
or something.
- Again, whenever I sleep,
I always know how much time
has passed when I wake up.
I don't understand how.
- Yeah.
Sydney has a lot of
nightmares when she sleeps.
And I know when she's
going through a nightmare
because she's just in panic mode.
I can tell when she's running
away from a fucking monster,
because she's just, (breaths rapidly)
like that.
- Too much NTR.
(laughing)
I don't know.
I have to wake her up and be like,
"You were in a nightmare, honey.
Don't worry. Don't worry.
You're in the safe zone.
I'm here. I'm here."
- Is she like when a dog
has a dream of running
and they just start kicking their legs?
- Yes.
(laughing)
It's so obvious.
Not only when Syndey is dreaming,
but the type of dreams she's having.
Because she won't say words
but she'll make noises,
depending on the type
of mood that she's in.
So if she's having a nightmare,
which is most of the time,
she'll start panicking.
She'll have a panic attack in her dreams
and all this kind of shit.
When she's happy she'll just laugh
and just smile at all this shit.
It's so obvious to say,
sometimes I see her
and she just as the
biggest smile on her face,
I'm just like, "I wish I
was you right now, Sydney.
Because you're having
a fun dream right now."
- I don't know why seeing someone
with a huge fucking grin as they sleep
is the creepiest ever.
Could you just imagine
walking into the room
and someones just as they sleep?
- That's really creepy.
- That's so creepy.
- I completely forgot.
I don't scream, sometimes I
physically laugh myself awake.
Something really funny happens
or someone said a really funny joke,
and I actually physically laugh.
And I was just like, "Oh. I was dreaming"
- Now that you mention it,
I don't think I've ever had funny dreams.
- I've never had a funny dream either.
- You've never had funny dreams?
- No.
- No, wow.
That's so strange. Now
that you've mentioned that.
- I'm depressed, even in my dreams.
(laughing)
- It's always something
fucking extreme in my dreams.
- Okay. I've never had funny dreams
where I guess I'm in a deep sleep,
but most of the times.
Have you ever had a micro dream?
It's when you're really, really tired,
and you're not completely,
It's so weird to describe
because you don't feel like
you're completely asleep
but then you start
hallucinating some shit.
- Like a day dream?
- No. Not like a day dream.
What does a day dream count to you?
Count for you?
- Day dream is just, you're
just bored, sitting there
and you just start imagining some shit.
- No, no, no.
So you're actually,
really physically tired
and you start going to sleep.
You're not completely in a deep sleep
but you still start dreaming as well.
So it's half,
I would say it's like half a lucid dream
because it's so easy.
Sometimes I wake myself up by falling over
and you get the fucking jerk,
and you're like, "Oh, fuck."
- The Inception method.
And you're just like, "For fuck's sake.
I was so, I was so close to being asleep
and then I had to jerk myself awake.
And then sometimes someone
says something funny
in that brief, micro dream
and I laugh myself awake.
I was like, "For fuck's sake.
I was so close to sleeping.
I was so close to actually being asleep."
- I want to be there
when you experience that.
Just to see how fucking weird
it is from my perspective.
Just Garnt just sitting
there and just, (chuckles)
"Oh."
- I've never seen Garnt do this.
- Yeah. It's weird.
- I very rarely micro dream.
I don't know, it's really weird.
You must have had the dream
where you jerk yourself awake.
Have you ever had that?
- You could've phrase that better.
- Why are you saying it like that?
- You could have phrased that better.
- Your body literally jerks
because you hallucinated that you're,
Is there another word I could use?
I feel like that's the best,
- Jolt.
- Jolt?
- Okay. Jolt yourself awake.
- "Did you jerk yourself awake?"
- Yeah. "Did you jerk your,
Oh, thank God. You're awake."
- "Oh, I'm back, baby.
I'm back."
- Oh, thank God.
- Jolt. I've never used the word jolt.
- I'm going to wake up, aah.
- I don't think I've
ever used the word jolt.
- We need some synonyms
for jerk right now.
- I've had those stereotypical,
on the train times,
where you're just closing your eyes
because it's a long rain ride.
And you have that thing
where you fall forward
and you're just like that.
Is that what you mean?
- No.
I'm talking about where you literally-
- Or you're literally in the dream?
- You're literally in half a dream
and then you imagine falling
over or tripping over.
- Oh, that happens a lot.
Yeah. I do that.
I kick my leg out or something.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's what I'm talking about.
But instead of imagining that I'm falling,
sometimes I imagine someone
saying something funny
or something funny happening
and then I just laugh.
- So it's an emotional joke.
- Yeah, yeah. It's like an emotional joke.
- No I don't have that.
I don't have that at all.
- Sometimes you imagine
a ball flying towards you
and then you jerk yourself awake as well.
- Yeah. That's happened a lot.
- That's happened a lot
in my dream as well.
- It's weird
because sometimes I won't
be dreaming of anything
and then it will very quickly cut
to a ball being thrown at me.
- Yeah, yeah.
I don't understand why that happens.
- Think fast.
- I'll literally not be in a dream,
not a dream, not a dream.
And then something just
flies at me and I'm like,
And then I just fall back to sleep.
It's not like I'm full awake.
- No. That's what I mean.
It's a micro dream where
you're not fully asleep
but you're not fully awake.
And then you brains just
like, "Haha, think fast."
Think fast, mother fucker.
(laughing)
- I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding.
You're fine.
Go back to bed. Go back to bed.
You all right.
- Like sleep walking.
- It's just a prank.
- Have you ever met
anyone who sleep walks,
ever sleep walk yourself?
- No. No.
- My uncle, apparently, used
to be a really, really bad
sleep walker and sleep talker.
My dad would tell me
stories of how my uncle,
because they used to sleep in a bunk bed.
- So bizarre, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- It's such a crazy thing.
And then he'd just,
there was one time where,
Actually, no.
I have a story of when
I sleep walked once.
The only time, apparently,
that I ever sleep walked,
was when I was little.
I was maybe four, five years old,
and apparently I walked
into my parents room
and I was asleep.
And my mum saw it.
She was like, "What the
fuck are you doing?"
And the she realized
that my eyes were closed.
And she was like, "Oh,
fuck. He's sleep walking.
I was saying something to her
but it wasn't really words.
It was just like, (babbles)
- "Wake up, you dumb fuck."
- No.
The moment she went,
"Wake up, you dumb fuck.",
was when I walked over to
the corner of their room
and there was a washing basket,
and apparently I pulled my
pants and tried to pee into it.
- No. That's so weird.
(laughing)
- And then my mom was like, (exclaims)
- I have a worryingly
similar story. Not of me.
(laughing)
- That's so crazy.
So my little brother had a sleep over
with one of his friends.
And I was the one who was,
I'd stay out awake a little
longer than I should have.
I played on my Game Boy, whatever.
And our house, the floorboards
creek really fucking loudly.
And obviously I've been
in this house for years,
so I could tell, based off what creek,
where someone was in the house
and where they were coming from.
And what point they were on the stairs,
what point they were
like some kind of fucking Dare Devil shit,
except only for my house.
So I heard someone who kept walking
to the middle top of the stairs
and then back to my little brother's room,
and then back to the stairs,
and then back to my little
brother's room really slowly.
And then after this
happened twice, I was like,
"What the fuck?"
So I went and I watched,
and he just walked to
the top of the stairs,
mumbled something and then went back.
What the fuck?
And then he went to the top of the stairs,
and this is where I was getting worried
because I'm like, "What if
he just like falls down?"
- Yeah, yeah.
That's dangerous.
- So he just starts walking
down the stairs really slowly,
and this is where I was
like, "What do I do?"
Because I didn't know
what you're supposed to do
when someones sleep walking.
I've heard loads of,
you've heard myths like,
" IF you wake them up they
can die.", or something.
So I was like, "It seems
like he's doing it okay."
I didn't want to wake him up
because what If he wakes up
be like,
I would.
I'd jump.
- It's like, "Think fast."
- "Haa. You're awake"
(laughing)
I was like, " Shit. What do I do?"
So I see that he starts
walking down the stairs
but doing this thing where
he's going back and forth,
so I'm like, "Guh."
And I saw that he was mumbling,
so was like, " I think
he's sleep walking."
So I go, I follow him,
and he's going down the
stairs really slowly,
and he gets to the bottom of the stairs,
and so I go to the bottom of the stairs
and then he opens the
door to the living room
and just goes in the living room.
This is like the fucking,
I don't know, this was a horror film.
He stood there, pitch black
because I didn't turn the lights on.
- Oh, my God.
It's so scary.
- All I had was my Game Boy SP Advanced,
so I light the thing.
(laughing)
I didn't want to turn the lights on
because I didn't want to-
- Think Phasmaphobia.
- I was like, the shitty
max brightness slider up,
trying to figure out what's
going on and I see him.
And he's just standing there mumbling
for a good 10, 20 seconds.
And I'm freaking out
because I'm like, "What do I do?"
Do I go and wake my little brother up,
do I go tell my parents?
Because I don't know
what he's going to do.
So I was just watching him, making sure.
Bare in mind, I was 14, 15.
I didn't know what the fuck was going on.
And so he's standing there in
the middle of this living room
and then just slowly starts
walking towards the T.V
and then walking back to where he was.
And then he walks to the T.V,
and there's my video games
all there in one of those old,
2000's metal racks where
you just slide it in.
And then he just starts
pulling down his pants
and then I was like, "No, no, no, no."
I was like, "Not on my games"
(laughing)
And that's where I woke
him up and I was like,
"No, no, no, no, no."
And then he woke up was
and was like, (babbles).
Like that. It was really weird.
- How did he react to you just standing-
- He acted like I was the weirdo.
(laughing)
I remember that.
I remember being like,
"What are you, What?"
He reacted like I was being
weird because I was like,
"Stop. Stop.", shaking him.
- Yeah. I was exactly the same as well.
My parents were like, "What
the fuck are you doing?"
And I'm like, "What do you
mean what the fuck am I doing?"
And then I looked down
and my pants were down,
and I was like, "Oh.
Okay that makes sense."
- He hadn't gotten them
down but he was undoing them
And that's where I was like,
"You're not pissing on
my fucking PS2 games."
- Oh, no. My pants were fully down.
My hand was on my dick
and I was ready to go
on this full basket of laundry.
I was like, "Oh."
- So when you woke up,
did you momentarily think
they were the weirdos?
- Yeah.
- Okay. See?
That's what...
- Because I looked over and my
mum was, really worried look
and shaking me.
- That's what I got.
- I'm like, "What's the problem?"
- I didn't even really know this kid.
I barely knew him so I
was, we never really,
Whenever I saw him, it was
always awkward after that
because he just always
remembered that time
where he woke up, and I
was like, "What the fuck?"
- Well, he almost pissed on your games.
- Yeah.
He nearly pissed on my PS2 collection.
My Wii, probably, I
don't know what it was.
(laughing)
- Did you ever get to the point
where there's something
happening in the real world,
where you hear a sound or something,
or you need to go to the toilet
and it gets integrated into
your dream for a good while?
- I don't know, Maybe, but
I probably don't remember.
- The most annoying thing for me is,
is when I need to go to
the toilet in my dream
because I don't immediately
wake up when I go to the toilet
or when I need to go to the toilet,
but luckily my brain has a disconnect
between my body and my brain
because there has been several times
where I really, really needed-
- I'd shit the bed.
- There's been several times
where I really, really needed to piss.
In my dream, I don't know I'm dreaming
but I acknowledge the fact
that I really, really need to piss.
So I've had several five
minute pisses in my dreams
and the feeling of the
piss just won't go away
because obviously I'm
only pissing in my dream
and not in real life.
So I'm urinating and I get
so frustrated in my dream
because no matter how much I urinate,
the feeling of needing to
urinate never goes away.
- That's really weird.
- If I feel something, if
I piss myself in my dream,
I'm pissing myself really.
That's 100% happening.
- I almost shit myself doing that once.
(laughing)
- Hold up. Hold up.
First of all, let me ask
another few questions.
How can you replicate
the feeling of pissing
so accurately in a dream?
To me, that's weird.
- Without actually pissing
in real life.
- I can't replicate feelings.
I know that it's not
accurate in the dream.
Does that make sense?
When I get punched in a dream,
it doesn't feel like a real punch.
I can distinguish between that.
- Okay no.
For me it feels real.
- You must be on some
Inception, fifth level dream.
- Yeah. I'm not getting this shit.
What are you experiencing?
- We're still on level one.
- I'm sad that I'm like, "So what?"
- I'm like five level deep,
- Holy shit, bro.
- Five levels deep
and I'm in front of this urinal, pissing,
and I'm just like,
"Why is the feeling
urinating not going away?"
- Holy shit. You're on some other level.
- Is there an establishment
shot of the toilet as well
before you start?
(laughing)
- You're at level 10 dreaming.
I'm at level two.
This is insane.
- Yeah. I don't know.
At some point in the dream,
I just give up on trying to
get rid of this urination.
I go on with the dream and
then I wake up and being like,
"Oh.
That's why I needed to
piss, because it was a dream
and I need to piss in real life.
- And you hadn't pissed your pants?
- No. I hadn't pissed my pants.
And I had the most
satisfying piss in my life
when that happens.
- Because, for me, every
time I've had a dream,
when I was a kid, of going to the toilet,
I have 100% pissed my pants.
(laughing)
I wake up and I'm just like, "Oh, fuck".
- I love the confidence.
I'm doing it. 100%
- And because of that, one
time I almost shit myself
when I was asleep.
- And he's 24.
- Here's the problem of
growing up with a bidet your whole life
and with a heated toilet seat,
is the fact that, as a kid,
you're just ingrained into your head of,
"Oh, my butt is warm?
I'm sitting on a toilet."
(laughing)
so in my dream I'm on the toilet
and can feel that my butt is warm
because it's a heated toilet seat.
So in my head I'm like, "Oh, butt warm.
I'm on a toilet. This is reality.
I'm actually going to take a shit.
And so in my dream,
I remember I almost start taking shit
but then I was like,
"Something's not right.
Why can I not shit right now?"
I had the feeling that I
needed to shit but I couldn't.
Nothing was coming out.
And it wasn't a
constipation type of thing.
It was literally I know I need to shit
but nothing's coming out.
- How come we always talk about shit?
- And then I woke up
and I was like, "Oh, now
I actually need to shit."
I was prairie dogging.
I was like, "Oh, God.
I was this close to
shitting myself in my bed.
- That's so strange.
In my dream I'm able to
communicate to my non-dream brain
being like , "Oh, you need to piss."
- Oh, no. I'm not like that.
- So I can stop the
dream if I need to pee.
I can control that.
- Oh. There's been so many instances
where I know I'm in a
dream, I'm in a nightmare.
- No. It's every time.
I'm in a nightmare. I
know I'm in a nightmare.
I can't wake up.
I'm just like, "Garnt, wake
up now. Please wake up."
- I remember one time I was getting chased
by this murderer or someone like that.
It was like a scene out of,
What's that Jack Nicholson film?
The Shining.
It was like the scene out of The Shining,
where I'm getting chased
by fucking Jack Nicholson
or something and I knew
I was in a nightmare,
I just didn't want to
experience dying in the dream
because it still felt real.
- Yeah. Of course.
- And I'm just like, "Garnt, wake up."
Nothing happens.
I'm like, "Garnt, I know
you're dreaming right now,
I know you're fucking dreaming,
fucking murderer goes around the corner,
start fucking legging it.
I'm like, "Garnt, I know
you're dreaming right now.
Wake up"
And my body refused to
wake up until I died.
I don't know why my
brain is such an asshole
that I can't wake myself up.
- It's like, "Nah. You
want to experience this.
- But I think I can only force,
I choose to wake up when
I need to pee or shit.
- Okay. Okay.
- Oh, I can't even do that.
- In the dream, I'll feel it.
I know that when I'm
experiencing this dream,
that I can feel this urge.
- Sensation, yeah.
- And I know that I need to do it.
I won't stop the dream
unless I get to a point
where it feels uncomfortable,
and then I think I'll just
be like, (exhales sharply)
- Damn. You're on 5G, I'm on dial up.
- I don't know.
It's so strange.
- "You need to piss.
You need to piss."
And my brains like, "All right. Hold on
Sending the morse code right now.
It's going to take a while."
- Weird, man.
I wonder.
- And then it's too late.
- I'm sure people in the comments
have even weirder dreams.
- I'm curious now
because I don't think I've
ever had such an in depth talk
about my dreams before.
- I've never spoken
- I didn't even know it was,
I thought it was normal that
you knew you were in a dream.
I thought that was normal.
- That's a lucid dream.
That's why they call it a lucid dream.
- It's not for you.
- I feel like everyone had that.
Because that's mainly the one I have.
- I've tried using methods to lucid dream
because there's tutorials on,
"Here's how to lucid dream."
One of them was like, "Cut
a ping pong ball in half
and put them on your eyelids.
And I'm like,
- So people want to lucid dream?
- Yeah.
- Why?
- Because they want to
control their dreams.
They want to do whatever
they want in their dream.
- Because most people when
they now they're in a dream
can control their dream.
- Yeah.
I have no, 99 times out of 100,
I have no control of my dreams.
- It's weird. When I have-
- Why would you want to
control your dream, though?
- So you can do whatever
the fuck you want.
- Just use you imagination.
Just fucking do it normally.
Do it awake.
(laughing)
- No. I can't fly in my dreams.
I can't fucking
run at a million miles an hour.
- I can if my brain forces
me to experience it.
But I can't just be like,
I can't just be like, "All right.
Tonight I'm going to dream
about fucking 100 bitches.
I can't do that.
- Doesn't that take away
the excitement of dreams
if you choose what you're doing?
- No. It just means,
like I said, it's literally, to me,
it's like playing GTA with cheats on.
Where you just have fun.
To me, it's just having
fun in this open world.
At that point people are NPCs,
when I realize that this is
a dream and I'm just like,
"Haha. I can do whatever I want.
I can fly to a different city.
Yeah. I can jack cars."
Its fucking great. I have so much fun.
- Weird.
- I would be interested
in someone psycho analyzing our dreams.
- Yeah. Honestly.
- Because we all, obviously,
have three different
perspectives on how we dream
and the experiences we have when we dream.
- It's so bizarre.
- This has been
a very bizarre episode of "Trash Taste".
- Dreamologists out there,
is that what they're called?
- Dreamologists.
- Sounds like a Disney job.
- Dreamologist?
- Yeah.
What are your experience with dreams?
Do you relate to us?
Do you have something entirely different?
Let us know because I, Genuinely I-
- Joey or Kahn?
Garnt.
- Garnt.
(laughing)
Connor, Joey or Garnt.
- Genuinely because I've
never heard of anyone, really,
talking about their dreams in depth.
- [Connor] Strange.
- Yeah. This is a first
time for me as well.
- Wow. Weird.
- You know what isn't weird though?
Our Patreons.
- Hell yeah, they're not.
- I bet they have awesome dreams.
(laughing)
- Hell yeah.
- They can control their dreams
(Garnt laughing)
just like you can control yourself
by supporting us on Patreon
at patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also, follow us on Twitter,
send us your memes in the subreddit,
and if you head up face,
listen to us on Spotify.
- I can't wait or the fucking
memes of this episode.
Like the fucking wacky
fucking dreams that we've had.
(laughing)
it's going to be the wildest
week in the subreddit.
- Oh, my God.
- Yeah.
But that's been this dream
filled episode of trash taste.
- Don't worry. This wasn't a dream.
- This entire episode has felt
like a fucking fever dream.
That's how this episode started, actually.
Talking about fever dreams.
- I'm going to wake
myself up from this dream.
Sorry, I need to piss.
- All right. Have a good one, guys.
Bye.
- Bye.
(gentle RnB music)